Four three,
two.
Hello Andy.
What's up?
Just going on,
but you're drinking CBD water.
I've never had CBD water.
GTS.
Kombucha sent us some CBD water.
My first sip was a few seconds ago and uh,
I didn't read that.
It said cucumber basil.
So as shocked by the taste,
but I like it.
Yeah.
That's a weird Combo,
right?
Yeah.
Cucumber.
And it's called Dream Catcher,
which makes me think of like white trash lady live in a trailer park one.
I'm things hanging over her bed.
Right.
Partially broken on the inside.
Mollett weird cats.
If you have a dream catcher,
most likely you have cats,
right?
I think you have to have one.
It's part of the program.
Yeah,
it's a package deal.
It's like,
you know what I saw yesterday,
the,
that is really rare.
I saw a dude who was dressed up like a native American who was not,
in fact a native American.
That's a risky move in this day and age.
Yeah.
I'm not going to go there.
I wouldn't kid.
You could be an Indian.
Like if you could play cowboys and Indians,
you can be an Indian and it'd be like,
oh,
okay.
Yeah,
no problem.
He's,
he's,
he's the Indian.
This guy's the cowboy.
Normal Shit.
Hey,
they will fucking come for you.
That day is gone.
It's the days over.
Yeah.
What happened?
I'm not smart enough to answer that question,
but she saw Traficant margin,
but some things have taken place.
I mean,
during the time that you were serving from 2001 to 2019 where we're at today,
I mean there has been a significant change in outrage culture in this country,
in,
in entitlement.
Like things that people think that they can get offended by and not offended by
things that are important and not important.
So we're under the strangest time.
The beauty of that is most of the time I was serving,
so it paid zero attention to any of it.
The disaster part of that is when you come off the off ramp,
you know,
out of service and you go,
what happened?
Yeah,
what happened to the environment that I left?
But I mean I went from Santa Cruz,
California where I grew up where it could well be the origin of outrage culture
and social justice warriors to the military to back out of the military.
So I had very,
a very different optics when it comes to perspective,
where I started and then what I was seeing when I came out.
Well that's,
that's the take that I always see from people that are in the military or have
been in the military is there,
understanding what's important and not important is so much different because
it's truly life and death.
Not all the time,
but I think if you are exposed to that environment enough,
it'll recalibrate.
Uh,
your perspective of what's important and what's not.
Yeah.
Did you ever,
I'm reading any Sebastian younger.
I did.
Did you try it?
Try a book?
Yes.
Bread that off your recommendation actually.
Did it speak to you like in terms of like your own personal experience,
it made complete sense.
I probably would have used different terms in different places throughout,
but the concept that he was talking about absolutely made sense.
I mean this,
so the seal teams,
one of the,
whether or not people live up to this,
an argument could be made,
but one of the key tenants is,
you know,
the Brotherhood,
which is it just another way of talking about a tribe?
Yeah.
Um,
I just felt like it was really interesting to me like the book that one of the
most moving part of it was how connected these people are when they're together
and when they're at war and what that brotherhood that C'mon comradery means to
them and how they feel disconnected when they're back in regular civilization
and they get depressed.
It's like their life had been led at such a,
such a high vibration intensity,
so much,
so much on the line.
It means so much.
Everything means so much.
It's so much dedication.
So much commitment.
And then to go back to the regular life is very,
very difficult for a lot of people.
Yeah.
I don't think it would be unfair to say that some of the people that I serve
with,
I probably have closer relationships than I do with my biological family.
Even,
probably I've shared,
I don't know,
not that it's not that the thing is that we shared were important,
but the value and our connection was so tight.
That honesty tighter than my definitely biological family and potentially even
my wife as well too in my own kids.
And that's Holler that out loud.
I think she understands it.
She gets it.
You're going to get in trouble bro.
If that's,
well I only get in trouble from my wife on days that end and why so nothing's
going to be new about that.
But I,
but I think she also understands that because I certainly have struggled.
I struggled quite a bit.
But about the first 18 months I got out of the military and I look back on it
now and I think the two pieces of it,
one,
I went from seeing those people that I share those experiences with on a daily
basis.
So there's that.
Everything you have in common,
we talk about stuff the same.
I mean I just know the ins and outs of those people and then I became detached
from them.
And then I had,
I used to have what I thought was a job that had an immense amount of purpose
and then that was gone too.
So I lost a little bit of my identity and a little bit of the purpose.
And at that same time,
like I said,
I come off that off ramp of being in the military and I'm looking at the world.
It doesn't make any sense to me at all.
People are arguing about things and uh,
talking about how they're oppressed while they're standing in a Starbucks line,
paying for a coffee that costs more per ounce than gallon of gasoline,
you know,
stuff that probably couldn't be a,
you could couch it in terms other than oppression and none of it made sense and
you just,
it's,
it's rough when you get to detached from that environment.
Well,
especially in your situation,
you were wounded and you,
you know,
although you wanted to continue serving,
you physically weren't able to anymore.
I
was for awhile,
so I got hurt in February of 2005 the 14 year or 15 year now,
14 year anniversary.
It was earlier this month and it took me about two years to work my way back to
where I would become operational again.
And I did one more deployment after I got hurt.
And then at the tail end of that deployment,
that was just the end of it.
My body wouldn't tolerate it anymore.
And this is because of the metal fragments or would it,
what is it totally you there?
Was it nerve damage?
It was the,
so I got medically retired,
which is not based off of any one instant,
hopefully.
I mean people who have,
so they get an IUD strike and they'll become a quad amputee or a triple amputee.
That's one incident that they're going to get a retired four.
For me it was more the culmination of a lot of things.
So the gunshot wound obviously didn't help.
Um,
and then the operational history of exposure to explosive blasts,
the concussive forces,
all of those things just kind of added up.
I went through a 30 day protocol where they baseline me and took a bunch of
tests and basically came to the,
you know,
they write out a massive document of all the things that they were able to at
least document.
Like for me,
I can't get an Mri because I still have metal in my body from Ferris metal from
the round that clipped a piece of rebar on its way to me.
Oh Wow.
And it clipped my sidekick nerve on the way in and they're concerned that if
they image me or what I've been told by the doctors,
if they image me,
it might react again with my sciatic nerve.
Just pull a piece of metal by it and I'll be right back where I was.
I'll ha I had dropped foot for about six months and he's rob foot is when your,
your foot just stops working.
Totally hangs.
I could always push down but I couldn't lift it up.
That's a thing that's happening now in MMA quite a bit.
It's happened several times when guys get low calf kicked and there's something
about chopping at the,
the nerves behind the leg that a guy's legs or just their foot's going limp.
It happened to Michael Chandler a,
it happened to Henry.
So Hutto are they recovering from it?
Yeah,
yeah.
I mean it's in the middle of the fight.
So just a military stops working in and they can't stand on their foot.
That's literally does,
he doesn't react anymore.
So frustrating.
So for me,
I got,
uh,
I got shot in the hip high up on my left hand side,
but by the time I made it to the hospital,
my single complaint was my ankle.
I was just telling me that I,
like,
I,
I didn't remember falling on my ankle.
I did remember hitting my ankle,
but it felt like somebody had taken a sledgehammer and just beat it into powder.
And so they were very careful in the,
you know,
they cut my shoes off me,
they cut my pants off me and they,
the first thing they did was take a extra in my ankle and they're like,
dude,
you're totally fine.
But it felt like it was destroyed because it was the nerve they got interacted
with high up.
It's short circuit all the way down to the terminal point of the nerve and for
me it never came back.
I'm hoping that obviously for the fighters that eventually comes back because I
had dropped foot for six months to a year.
I eventually was able to start a dorsal flexing my foot again,
but I still can't feel my left leg from the knee cap down on the side,
the far left hand side and as it wraps over the top of my foot is completely
numb.
And is this because of um,
the actual damage to the nerve or something touching the nerve?
They don't know.
That was an interesting part of being hurt as well is talking to people who have
decades of medical experience and having them look at you and go,
I don't know.
Fuck yeah.
Especially without an MRI.
Right.
Cause they can't,
they can't and they cause they're worried about it being pulled out.
Same thing.
Why the concussion history that I have,
it's an estimate based off of operational history because they can't throw me in
that same machine and image of my brain.
Oh whoa.
Because it's spinning magnets and there's metal all over,
uh,
the left hand side of my pelvis.
And I don't know how much you would have to move,
but if it just clipped that nerve again,
I mean it was probably one of the more difficult times in my life.
My leg felt like it was on fire 24 hours a day,
which I could ignore during the daytime.
But where it got me was at nighttime,
I would lay down in bed and it just felt like I had did my leg and gas and just
put a lighter onto it.
So I was on high doses just of like Gabapentin and Neurotin,
which are central nervous system suppressors.
So I started feeling the cognitive effect of that.
So I backed myself off of that wasn't an a great phase of my life.
So I was of course washing those down with massive amounts of alcohol,
taken three to four ambien staying awake because my tolerance stole.
All that stuff was so high.
And the last thing I ever want to do is go through that again.
So I'm going to stay away from the spinning magnets just cause,
I mean it might be a quarter of an inch and I'd be exactly right back where I
was before and there is no way they can go in and pull those fragments out.
So I'm laying in a hospital in Baghdad in the night that I got hurt.
Uh,
many other people got hurt.
Eight people got hurt on that particular target.
I was one of the least injured.
There were people who immediately flown into surgery.
A guy almost lost his arm.
Um,
a guide took a,
he was right next to an explosive blast that literally peeled back the layers of
his ballistic helmet.
He was conscious but blind.
He'd taken such a shot to his head.
He got ejected out the backside of the building.
There was some other gunshot wounds.
So I'm laying in the hospital bed.
I hadn't taken any morphine because I had watched too many movies and I thought
if I had,
I had auto injector Seretse on me at all times,
but I thought if I had jabbed myself I was going to start drooling,
no experience with whatsoever.
And the doctors finally started working on me and
he says,
all right,
we're going to take a look at this.
I'm going to,
you know,
I'm going to basically stick my finger in the hole.
And I was like,
what?
This,
take a pause here sir,
can I have some pain medication?
So he comes out and just juices me with Morris Fain.
First Time I've ever had it was,
I wish I would've taken it in the field.
It did almost nothing.
And they played around a little bit with the holes and then slipped me into an x
ray machine and said,
do you want us to try to take this out?
And I said,
well what does that going to entail?
And he said,
well,
because we can tell that there's Farris metal in here.
What we would do is we would knock you out,
put a tube down your throat,
lay you on your stomach and hold up a two dimensional ex-ray and basically just
start slicing and pulling apart,
slicing and pulling apart,
looking and searching these metal pieces and pulling them out of your body one
at a time.
And I said,
is there another option?
He's like,
oh yeah,
totally.
The body will encapsulate it in calcium and as long as it's not touching a bone,
you're probably going to be fine.
What the fuck,
man?
Why don't you lead with that option,
right?
Well,
did they think that we're going to be able to get them all out though?
If they did go in there and start slicing away,
I don't know.
And I don't know what benefit it would have had.
I suspect it would have caused more damage than the actual injury itself.
My hip is fine.
Um,
I still have never had a surgery.
I've still never broken a bone.
The only thing they ever did was put a gauze pad all my leg and when the scab
fell off I could start taking a bath again if I wanted to.
Wow.
Yup.
They just left everything in there.
Jesus.
That's crazy.
It's all covered.
Bizarre.
Wow.
So if you do have an injury now that it's,
is it a lot of guesswork?
Like if something's wrong with your leg,
did they have to like go in there with a scope?
Like I of them too can't get an MRI.
Like what have you blew your knee out?
They would have to rely on imagery.
Technology that doesn't revolve around magnets.
So most likely I'm not too,
I think they gave me a cat scan in the hospital so that I don't think his magnet
based and then two dimensional x-ray.
Well it's interesting too because some of the therapies they're using on people
for Tbi is magnets,
but I don't think there is powerful as an Mri.
I mean you can't even wear earrings in those rooms.
We yet with an MRI and heard about some kid who accidentally died because he had
an oxygen tank in the room and they turned the machine on and the tanks slammed
into him and crushed him.
Yeah,
I've heard about the Tbi magnets that I think I would be fine with because I
don't think it has the power that the huge machines do.
Right,
right.
It's,
yeah,
it's like a low frequency magnetic pulse.
That's like cat Zingano who a UFC fighter.
She essentially was,
she was,
she had been hurt and really bad in a fight with Amanda Nunez and she got
hypothyroid condition from that fight.
Her thyroid wasn't functioning correctly.
She was gaining weight like crazy.
She was,
her motor skills were all fucked up and they fixed her with that.
And that was from the brain injury?
Yeah,
for a fight.
She won,
which is crazy.
I mean she was hurt really bad in the first round.
Stopped her in the third round.
She won the fight.
She beat Amanda Nunez and you know,
really suffered some significant brain trauma from that fight.
There is a,
I don't want to say there's a rash of
suicides in the seal teams specifically.
Obviously the number 22 is thrown out a lot when it comes to veteran suicides.
But that's what does it,
22%,
22 veterans a day.
A conviction he said is the number that is often touted.
I,
I am hesitant to say that number is accurate because if you look at how it was
derived,
it wasn't,
they could have done a better job of getting that number and it,
and I don't want to say inside of the seal teams if there's a suicide issue,
it'll,
even though I do know a few people that have committed suicide and they were the
ones that I would least expect it from,
but they were also the ones who had,
uh,
quite a bit of a high operational tempo.
And the one thing that I don't think,
especially in the military medicine world,
they understand well as traumatic brain injury and the impact it has longterm
and how easy it can be.
Because you know,
this,
uh,
I've heard you talk about it before.
You don't have to get knocked out to get a brain injury.
Right.
And I know I've countless times where I either did something dumb or was just
standing in the wrong place or had a hard parachute opening and I cracked my
head against the metal risers in your head hurts for the rest of the day.
Yeah.
And it's,
I've seen the change in behavior in some people and I,
I know the stuff that's tied to it as well,
the low hormones,
all of that stuff there that is happening I think at the highest levels in the
military,
probably military wide,
but specifically those people who were kind of more on the front leading edge of
combat operations.
And I think as a country we're in a,
we're at a total unknown area because we're in a sustained period of war longer
we've ever been as a nation and nobody knows the outcome of that.
And people who I would've never guessed would make the decision to take their
own life.
I'll get a text and hey,
you know,
so and so just went out into the woods and no other external injury.
No other marker.
Then obviously something happened in the geometry between their ears that caused
them to make that decision.
And I suspect it's from the repeated exposure to the brain injury.
Yeah.
It's something that people are just starting to understand over the last couple
of decades.
I mean obviously a,
there was a focus that concussion movie and you know,
I don't know if you saw that Bob Costas was actually pulled from football.
Uh,
and they,
they had told him that he'd crossed the line.
You can answer all causes.
They pulled him,
they pulled him from doing,
uh,
what,
what event was it?
Was it from the Superbowl because,
uh,
he was talking about traumatic brain injury and the realities of it and they
said,
you crossed the line.
He's like,
I crossed the line by talking about reality,
but an honest and open person.
Most not cool.
I mean,
that's what he does.
I mean that is Bob Costas,
his entire hook.
But I mean he's,
he's a brilliant guy.
But this,
uh,
this problem was so poorly understood just two decades ago.
So everyone's just sort of coming to this realization that,
I mean,
according to Dr. Mark Gordon,
who have,
I've had on who works with the Warrior Angel Foundation,
Andrew Mars,
uh,
set up where they're helping all these veterans that have traumatic brain
injuries.
And I've,
I've had Mr. Gordon on several times.
He says,
Hey,
you can get traumatic brain injuries from things that don't even remotely knock
you out.
He's like,
people get them from doing moguls when they ski.
They get them from,
from your brain,
just rattle and get them from jet skis bouncing around on jet skis.
I mean,
you can get it from a minor car accident.
You can have a traumatic brain injury.
And for guys like me that got hit in the head for years,
who knows what the fuck is going on in there,
you know?
And for professional
fighters it's,
you know,
it's almost inevitable for football players,
it's even worse,
you know,
for football players,
they did some crazy study and I know we quoted it and I don't remember what the
numbers was,
but at some insane number,
like in the high,
80% of people from high school on through college and into the professionals
have Tbi or CTE or the some signs of a traumatic brain injury.
I'd be surprised if they didn't give them.
They're fucking crazy.
It gets,
it is interesting too,
like I was saying,
so when I got medically retired,
they sent me to a medical facility called Nyco,
which is attached to Walter Reed and as the best care that I ever received
because it's a civilian facility.
It's called the national intrepid center of excellence.
We did a lot of work with them back in the day for the UFC.
The UFC raised a bunch of money for that.
Really?
Yeah.
Well,
the money was well spent because I went there and I probably would not have been
medically retired had I not because I left with literally 150 page dossier.
And,
but it's interesting tying it back to Tbi because I spent a lot of time as a
requirement talking to psychologists and psychiatrists and it the Tbi pts in the
military.
It gets interesting because it seems like they're treated as different issues.
And I'm probably misquoting the number a little bit.
I think there's 13 recognize symptoms of both,
but there's an overlay of like 11 so,
uh,
I can't remember any of these symptoms off the top of my head,
but you could describe one and it could apply both to Tbi and to post traumatic
stress.
So it gets even more muddled on how are you treating somebody for a brain injury
or are you treating somebody for a post traumatic stress?
Are you lumping everybody together?
It's just cause I see a lot of people and specifically a lot of veterans getting
stuck in that world where they've,
it's a lot of focus on pts,
but the reality is it could just be from the trauma received over a career or
you know,
nearly two decades for most people to make it to retirement.
It's really hard to tell.
Well apparently blasts are a big one,
right?
Like blowing down doors and things like that.
Even even even just step away and you brace yourself.
The impact of just the air,
the concussive force of it,
this is devastating for your brain.
The human brain apparently is just so much more delicate and sensitive than
anyone could have ever guessed.
We'll then concussive blasts are tough phone because they travel.
So if you're internally in a building and you find a door that's at the end of a
hallway,
even if you go all the way down to the end of the hallway and around the corner
of the blast can still get you because it will come down off the door,
reflect off of the hallway and still rocky.
Jesus.
Yeah,
it's,
I thought I had a good hiding spot more than once and did not have good,
how'd you sit and just be like,
oh that hurt more than one occasion or you're working with a bunch of assholes
who take all the good hiding spots,
goddammit it and just turned around and just ball up.
And there's not really much you can do about that.
Right?
I mean,
if you have to blow down that door,
someone has to be there to detonate and you have to be close enough for it to
activate.
Right.
Uh,
how are they doing it wirelessly?
They might be doing it wirelessly.
Now when I was in,
uh,
it was called known l,
um,
and it basically,
it's a or a shock tube.
So you put a charge of wherever,
adult,
a gate,
a door,
a wall,
and you basically have to attach an initiator to it cause the charge isn't going
to go off by itself.
So you need a highly reactive charge to set off an explosive that has less
reactive.
You keep them separate,
obviously for safety,
except for the main breacher.
He probably has at least one hooked up so he can be really fast.
But then you just extend that flash tube and it's,
they come in long reels.
I mean that you can get 30,
40,
50 feet and each charge,
mathematically we do math on it to determine the minimum safe distance of every
charge.
And it's written on the charge.
So you know how far you can get away.
But sometimes you're in a situation where,
like I said,
that you think you got an awesome hiding spot and the guy lays out the flash
tube and he's getting ready to fire it off and you realize that you're staring
directly at the charge and you have nowhere to hide and they're not going to
wait on you.
So it's turnaround cover up into a ball and eat it.
Oh,
is there a best way to eat it?
A open your mouth and cover your ears on Aly?
Yeah.
Open your mouth yet.
Allow instance instead of overloading,
uh,
like your sinus cavities and your,
your ear canal so you can cover ears and open your mouth.
It helps if someone's going to go off really close to you,
open your mouth and cover your ears.
Yup.
What,
what,
what's the difference between opening and closing the mouth?
Uh,
the effect of the wave.
Am I understanding that contain pressure inside of your body as opposed to
giving it a,
an avenue to escape Jesus Christ.
One of the things that realizing apparently about concussions is that even just
getting hit in the chest can give you concussion from the top of the head.
Cause you're,
you know,
you get hit in the chest and you're like,
I didn't even get hit in the head,
but just getting hit in the chest makes your head snap and it makes your brain
swish around inside your head.
And that's what gives you an injury.
I just remember earlier on,
I mean like the mid two thousands,
it wasn't,
the only question was does your head hurt?
Like that was the beginning of whether or not you might have sustained a
concussion.
And then obviously learning much more now and where we're at,
it's like,
yeah,
you may not have even had any sensation in your head,
but you know,
it's kind of crazy when you think about how long people have been studying the
human body and this is just something they've really go to a real understanding
of in the last couple of decades.
I don't even know if I would characterize it as a real understanding.
I think they're farther along than they work to two decades ago,
but I think the amount we know versus the amount that we don't know is much more
weighted on the amount we don't know.
Yeah.
I went to a high school football game recently,
uh,
cause my daughter was doing this cheerleading thing and I watched his kids
collide with each other and I'm like me,
I will fucking fight commentator,
you know,
and I'm watching this.
I'm like,
get out of there.
Stop doing it.
Yeah.
It's just to me it's,
I dunno,
it's,
I guess people,
I get that people enjoy the game.
I understand it.
I mean,
I think there's a lot of things in life.
I'm talking to you,
the world record squirrel suit flying,
jump,
man.
Tell when I talk about risk and reward maybe the wrong person to discuss this
with,
but you know,
my risk versus reward.
Well,
it's worked out for you so far.
You're here today.
Yeah.
I mean you're jumping off fucking mountains with a flying squirrel suit.
If you're here,
you've obviously got it nailed.
I'm on pause for the base jumping for the time being,
did uh,
miss his stump step in and put the Kibosh on it for the first
time.
She asked me to stop,
uh,
June of last year,
but of course it was tied to a very close friend who,
uh,
did a jump,
didn't go the way he wanted it to go or anybody would.
She happened to know him and it really was the,
it was the first time that I seriously considered giving it up.
I haven't touched a wingsuit since.
Uh,
my buddy Alex died and he was my main base jumping partner overseas on most of
the trips that I had done.
And I am not going to say I shepherded him into the sport,
but I was there with him on his first jump off of a cliff in Italy.
The first time you put a wing suit on and it's a,
that one stung a bit.
So it's on pause potentially forever.
As far as base jumping goes,
I'll still skydive,
but it's a,
it's a question mark on the base.
You do such risky shit.
The Sky,
I was like,
yeah,
skydiving.
That's no big dust skydive.
I'll jump out of a fucking plane that I will do with my eyes closed every day.
That's the high risk ratio on now one is we're,
we're all set.
What is the risk ratio on sky diving?
Like what percentage of those things go wrong?
It's incredibly low.
Um,
so that you have a main parachute and a reserve parachute.
I don't think there has been a true double failure,
meaning your main parachute malfunction.
So you cut it away properly and deploy your reserve parachute and have that also
fail in 20 some years.
People die skydiving all the time.
Well not all the time cause I guess you know,
the population of people that do it is not huge.
But I would say the vast majority of people who die skydiving,
they,
they kill themselves,
they make a poor decision.
Um,
and most people who die skydiving die under perfectly functioning equipment.
Really?
So the,
the canopy size,
the main canopy that you're flying the wing over your head,
the smaller it is,
the faster it goes,
the faster it descends.
But also,
quite frankly,
the more fun it is.
But with fun there's consequence.
So there our canopies that you can initiate a turn and if you initiate the turn
too low,
you cannot pull the canopy out of the turn.
You will impact the ground at a high rate of speed regardless of what you do.
And if you get under that canopy with not enough experience,
obviously your odds of making a bad decision,
you're going to go through the roof.
So most injuries and fatalities,
at least from the stuff I've seen is from people making poor decisions under
good equipment or choosing to execute an emergency procedure,
which would be cutting away your main parachute in deploying reserve,
either out of sequence or doing it too low or the reserve parachute doesn't have
time to open.
To me,
that's not a failure of the parachute system.
That's the failure of the individual who is driving that parachute system.
So if you have a main parachute and you jump out and you hit the main parachute
and there's a malfunction,
how do you cut it off to put,
to get the other one?
So there's two pillows,
one on each side,
the right hand side.
You literally need to do this in the correct order even though people have
killed himself by going backwards.
So you pull to full arm extension you,
it's literally just a pillow with velcro that has two cables and the cables are
what's actually holding the parachute on your shoulders.
If you pull that out,
a three ring release system,
which is basically just a load reduction system unwinds itself and your
parachute's gone and you're going back into free fall and you just pull the
other pill.
It sounds worse than it is.
And before I had my first cutaway,
it was terrifying.
And then after you have four or five,
you're like,
okay,
I got this.
I had four or five main parachutes fail.
I think I'm at about seven Andy,
well,
I've been jumping for 20 years.
I started jumping in 99 [inaudible] statistically I'm actually,
I think under,
uh,
I think it's like one in every 888 jumps,
you'll have a malfunction or a gear failure.
It's honestly like it's your first one is an emotional experience I would
imagine you're saying.
What was the first one?
Uh,
deploying a parachute and just sitting there looking at it as it's because they
want to open and you can,
I can tell now and within an instant of trying to deploy my pair of shoe,
whether or not it's going to open or not,
just by looking at the shape by sometimes listening to it and just seeing how it
opens sometimes.
I mean,
so packing a parachute people think is really difficult.
If you can fold a tee shirt,
you can pack a parachute.
Sometimes though you,
you know,
you just get off of the jump and you only have 10 minutes to make the next jump.
So you skip a few steps or you rush through a few steps.
Is that what happened with you?
Potentially.
I may have skipped all of the non essential steps and a few of the essential
steps to get the pair of shoes.
Really.
I was just rushing and I didn't have a lot of experience,
so I stuff in the thing in there and when I tried to deploy the parachute,
it just,
it was asymmetrical.
So sometimes it'll,
it'll open and it'll start spinning and then you're flying with your back to
the,
it gets,
that would be considered an exciting moment,
I would say.
So what happened with you?
What exactly went wrong?
It just came out asymmetrically.
The parachute wasn't opening and we were spinning.
No I wasn't.
I actually was able to recognize just by,
it should come out.
It looks like a rectangle more than anything,
but if you look like a rectangle with its twisted,
there's no way to fix that.
No Way.
So just get rid of it.
And that's what I did.
I looked up and I said okay,
that's not going to work.
Reach,
Pole,
reach,
pull and your reserve open so fast.
Like by the time I felt like by the time I had pulled the reserve handle,
cause I had a handle that point by the time I had moved my arm to three quarters
of extension at had fired off.
Wow.
Yeah Dude.
But the difference in you were asking what the difference,
like why is risk skydiving lower?
It's because you have time,
thousands of feet.
Whereas base jumping,
you might have hundreds or if you're really pushing the envelope,
you might have sub 10 feet because you're flying close to the ground to so you
can go did your friend Alex who died,
did he died base jumping or he died?
Wingsuit base jumping is something that I was,
I mean he was my main base jump partner.
What is the difference between wingsuit base jumping and regular base jump?
A regular base jumping.
You just have a quick deploy parachute,
right?
So you have one parachute system when you base jump instead of two because there
is not time for a reserve to open.
So that is just taken out of the system,
right?
So you pack your primary or only parachute very similar to a reserve.
It's designed to open rapidly.
It's designed to take a lot of load.
Uh,
but so base jumping is just jumping off of a aesthetic object based stands for
building antenna span or earth.
So four types of object.
The addition of the wingsuit is really the only difference which allows you to,
like for myself personally,
I'm not a huge fan of jumping off buildings and cliffs without a wing seat
because I don't like being from me to that flag when a parachute opens because
if it doesn't open exactly in the direction you want it to,
you better be Johnny on the spot or you're going to have a fucking problem.
So it's to me if you have enough altitude,
you put a wing suit on and two or three seconds,
the suit is mocking forward.
So then your hundreds if not thousands of feet away from the object,
then you pair,
she can open up however you want it to.
Have they made any improvements in the technology or this stuff since you first
started jumping?
Huge improvements.
I mean the first wing suits were literally just fabric that had like the little
thumb loops you'll find on like cold weather,
long sleeve shirts sometimes.
Seriously.
Like Patrick said,
he kept it on.
That's how they kept it on.
I didn't jump any of those goddamn things,
but I mean,
I think Patrick Day garden is how you say his name.
He was one of the first and they would just sit there and just,
they would just jam their appendages and lock them out and use their entire
musculature to sail this fabric as far out as they could get.
Fuck.
And then the suits now are unbelievable.
So each wing,
like the wing between your legs and the wing betweens,
each of your arms.
So there's three of them.
They're totally independent.
They have a ram air opening,
so the air rushes into that and makes the wing semi-rigid.
So it reduces the stress on your body and they,
their flight characteristics are insane.
You can go,
you can get the suit flying faster,
you can fly it flat or you can float it.
Everything about it is improved except for the decision making process of the
monkey who's actually jumping in.
That's the original one,
Jamie.
Oh,
that guy's dead for sure.
It says a man,
a Mickey Morgan,
where he's 100% of the bat wing suit.
Is that ridiculous?
Who Will,
who was the first fucking psycho that thought that this was something that they
should try?
It could potentially have been,
oh my God,
this guy is like,
he looks like he's living in the 18 hundreds.
When did they invent these fucking things?
I Dunno.
I know one of these guys died going off the Eiffel Tower in an exhibition.
This is 1900 right here.
Hundred.
What in the fuck?
Look at that guy strong.
You know what,
man,
if you were living in 1900,
you'd probably be like,
listen,
let's just get this over with.
Fuck living in 1900.
Everyone has syphilis.
Fucking whiskeys.
Illegal.
I'm just jumping off.
Look at that.
That is crazy to see that.
That's,
I mean,
honestly,
I'm not going to lie.
It would probably be jumped out of an airplane.
Teen 95.
Oh,
he's the inventor.
Earl Stein.
He died in the first attempt.
Oh,
Jesus Christ.
He died in the first attempt honor to a modern hero.
All right,
settle down.
But here's the thing,
Joe.
There's like 60 some people who are associated with,
uh,
the modern day wingsuit and testing and evaluating to get it to this point.
They're all dead.
All of them are dead.
Every one of them.
She,
but that
like,
I mean,
that suit and the difference between that and where we are now,
it's night and day,
but everyone involved in the creation of these wingsuits died in a wingsuit.
Yup.
Fuck man.
That is not good.
Like there wouldn't be a whole lot of black belts in Jiu Jitsu.
Everyone who got to a certain point died.
You know what I'm saying?
It's hard to justify or rationalize the behavior for sure.
I'll be the first person to add to,
what is it?
Like what,
what is it about that jump?
But it's dog.
That's dean potter,
which helped him with his dog.
Oh,
the port dog.
So the dog,
the dog's fault.
The dog,
I believe is that looks like Switzerland.
Crazy asshole fucking owner.
So Dean was in insane,
right?
He,
he's a Worldclass,
a rock climber.
He's also dead from jumping wingsuit.
He died and Yosemite's.
Um,
it's like I said,
the technology advances,
I am not,
I was not there the day the dean died.
I've talked to people who've looked at it as to the conditions that led up to
it.
And,
uh,
one thing people generally don't want to do is place the responsibility on the
individual making the choice.
But what from everything that I have seen,
he made a choice to jump at a time when he should not have been jumping due to
visual conditions.
So even though the suits are amazing,
really the only thing that doesn't seem to be evolving as the person that's,
that's jumping at it most of the time,
just like skydiving,
it's just a human being making a very poor choice to include.
What is it about people,
and I mean,
particularly people like yourself that love these thrills.
Like what are you getting?
What are you getting out of the,
other than this mad adrenaline rush?
I mean,
what is it like,
what
motivates you to keep doing that?
Uh,
so I look back at it objectively.
I think when I initially started pushing hard down that path,
I was trying to replicate a headspace or a feeling or a sensation that I had in
my old job.
So if you want to talk about clarity of thought,
and I think we might've talked about this the very first time that we sat down
stripping away all ancillary bullshit that has absolutely no meaning,
but for me at least spend,
I spend 99% of my time worrying about things that have no impact whatsoever,
right?
So you sit in on a helicopter,
pick the battle space that you're in and you,
you get a five minute warning and you really stop worrying about whether or not
you have enough money in your checking account to cover your mortgage.
And then you get a three minute warning and then you kind of stop worrying about
whether or not you just had an argument with your wife or you just sent off some
snarky email.
Then you get a one minute warning and a 32nd warning and the closer and closer
and closer you get,
everything has gone.
And it is still to this day,
the,
the sensation and state that I have been in that is by far I had no question
about,
uh,
my purpose and I had the utmost clarity that I've ever experienced in my life.
And you get,
you get used to operating in that headspace of just being in the moment,
the first one to three seconds in front of you,
nothing else matters.
I'm going to solve this problem and move on to the next one,
this problem and move on to the next one.
Well then I lost the ability to do that and it sucked because I liked operating
in that headspace because it,
it helped me deal with all the other bullshit in my life because it reset for
me.
My,
what matters and what doesn't matter.
Ratio.
I was able to get rid of it.
Like I would describe it,
it just the white noise in my head or go another way.
I'll describe it as like,
Jamie's got a bunch of levers that he can push up.
I think in this,
I'm included in this,
I think most people are pegged out at a 10 almost all the time.
They're fucking white knuckling through life.
But if you can get into that state where you have that clarity of purpose,
clarity of focus.
I felt like it pulled everything back to a three and so that state helped me in
things that had nothing to do with that activity and it lasted for a long time.
So when your base jumping and you're standing on a cliff and you're scared out
of your mind and you can't talk as your mouth is so dry and you have the p ring
on your suit,
which is why you always get dark suits so people can't see your p ring and
every alarm bell and your body is telling you don't jump.
And it had the same experience.
I wasn't worried about checking account,
wasn't worried about what was going on in life.
I was just living in that moment and it helped me be a better dad.
It helped me be a better husband.
It helped me be better at any business decision that I need to make because it
allowed me to pull all of those stereo levers back down so it's less for me and
I can only speak for me it's less about a thrill seeking cause I get that all
the time.
You're an adrenaline junkie.
I'm like,
ah,
I enjoy,
I'm an Adrenalin enthusiast.
I certainly enjoy that but I actually like what I get from the activity more
than the activity itself.
What do you think is going on where people are pegged at 10 all the time with
nonsense and that's something that's life threatening can bring it back to a
three and offer clarity.
I mean the has to be something that you've discussed or thought about in depth.
I just think it helps you
control alt,
delete your hard drive a little bit.
It helps by not having,
like when I'm standing on a cliff,
right before I get ready to jump,
there is absolutely nothing that I am thinking about other than where I want to
be in the next three seconds.
And by being able to focus on something so singular,
and maybe I don't,
I don't meditate,
but I've heard people talking about it and by a male to clear your mind,
it helps them deal with everything else.
I think there might be some connection there.
Um,
but I just,
I just think that
the removal of the noise that bombards everybody all day long,
even for a little bit,
helps you.
It's a,
you know,
you have a iPod or not iPod,
iPhone and head headphones for sure.
Right.
[inaudible] you ever noticed,
like when you're listening to it,
you listen at the same volume level,
but then it doesn't seem to be as loud.
So what do you do?
You Click it up a notch,
right?
And then you get used to that volume level and then you click it up a notch and
then you get used to that volume [inaudible] receptor downgrades phenomenon.
Your body gets used to it,
so it adapts to it.
But if you pull that stimulus out and leave it at that high volume,
but listen to it like two weeks later,
it's going to blow your ears out.
Hmm.
It'll seem loud,
it's going to blow your ears out,
but it's going to seem much louder than it would if you slowly just
incrementally started adding that volume.
So it's,
there's something in there that is allowing me,
and I'm not recommending that anybody pursue therapy via the directions that I
do,
but there's something in there that's allowing me to,
instead of ad an ad,
an ad,
that activity allows me to detach.
And then when I come back to it,
I realize,
you know,
it just,
it just feels different for me.
That's,
I don't know if that's a good description of the mechanism,
but that's the best that I can probably describe it.
Well,
I know a lot of veterans come back and really get involved in martial arts.
Martial arts apparently is good for along the same lines,
the same sort of a noise reduction.
Yup.
Uh,
especially Jujitsu when someone's trying to strangle you and you're fighting for
your life and their mountain.
You and trying to lapel ocho familiar with this now once in,
yeah.
I don't know what you're talking about.
Being strangled or choked.
We're having a huge person land your chest and just leave.
Oh my God,
he's lying about being two 20.
He could've said to 19,
I'm not even sure he's lying.
There's no,
I'm 200 pounds.
He's fucking 18 feet taller than me.
There's no way.
Yeah.
This is just a,
it doesn't even make sense.
Well,
I don't have enough experience
with Jujitsu to,
to truly speak about,
uh,
the longterm benefit.
But what I can say is this,
if I stop base jumping,
what I will replace that avid activity with his more Jujitsu.
Because what you just described when somebody is literally when you're
simulating murder.
Yes.
Right.
And your pajamas and somebody is trying to choke you to death.
Yeah.
You are not thinking about anything else about anything else.
You know,
one thing that I do do that's weird as a,
I have songs playing in my head.
Well you also probably have a few more reps than most people,
so you can have that capacity for songs in your head.
But they're weird songs like Christina Aguilar.
I am beautiful.
I like sometimes that'll be planned if I'm rolling,
but the song that's like,
it's almost like,
it sounds strange,
I never talked about this before,
but it's almost like a,
like a mantra.
Like I'll,
I'll play certain parts of the song over and over again in my head so that I can
think about that instead of the actual,
the actual training and the actual strangling.
But you also have,
I don't want to use the term mastered cause I don't know if you can master it,
but where are you?
Are you are at a,
like when you roll with somebody,
I was talking to somebody about this not too long ago.
When I roll with the black belt,
the outcome is preordained,
right?
Unless they bought their black belt at Macy's and her pretending in which case,
I don't know,
I still don't know enough.
It might be preordained,
but the difference in what I am thinking about versus what would happen if you
and I roll in what you are thinking about or is it going to be massive so I
don't have the hard drive space to sing Kristina Agular.
Yeah.
And you probably don't even remember half of the things that you do when you
roll or how you think about it because you have experienced it so many times.
The weirdest thing about Jujitsu and training,
and you know you could say this about striking as well,
is sometimes things happen and you didn't even think about doing them.
You just did it.
Those are the weirdest moments.
Like there's sometimes where you'll,
you'll kick somebody,
like someone will move and you'll,
you'll move and then before you know it you're like,
wow,
I didn't even think about throwing that and it lands.
It's like your,
your,
your brain recognizes,
oh,
I know what happens here.
You know,
you step to the left and throw that left kick and it just lands.
You just know where to go.
And then the same thing happens with Jujitsu.
Like sometimes there's a scramble and in the scramble,
all of a sudden you're choking somebody.
It's like this,
this movement happens and your body just falls into place.
I'll let you know if I ever experienced that particularly well.
It doesn't happen all the time.
There's moments where you're like it,
particularly if you do a lot of drilling,
which I don't know how much drilling you're doing,
but this one of the things that I,
it made me way better when I first started training with Eddie Bravo,
one of the things that we did a lot from white belt to blue belt time was a lot
of drills,
a lot of drills,
just constant drilling and drilling is overlooked and underappreciated because
sparring,
it's so fun.
So like if you and Jamie were both learning together,
you would do a few drills.
Okay,
here's how you do the arm bar.
You're going to secure the arm,
you know,
swivel the hips through the leg over and tap.
Good.
Okay.
Now your turn,
you do it over and over again.
That's fun.
Okay.
Now as far you're like,
all right,
take it easy guys.
Work on the technique.
Yeah,
exactly.
He's a guys work on the technique.
But um,
if you could spend more time drilling and less time rolling,
you'll be way better at rolling.
The whole idea is to dis carve these paths in your mind.
You know,
and then you,
you,
when you see someone who like hits a perfect image,
Arri roll,
like that is not the first time they've done that.
You know,
there's,
um,
uh,
there's,
there's so many like super,
super high level guys now that you could watch on youtube and you can watch them
execute these techniques and the thing that you're seeing more than anything,
it's like how fluid everything is and how easily everything flows because
there's so much efficiency in their movement because they've done it over and
over and over and,
but drilling is everything and it's the thing that people do the least of.
So I go when I'm home,
I'd go five days a week and I,
uh,
I go to the,
so you met Travis today.
Awesome.
He's the owner of a,
or the owner of Spg Kalispell,
which is where I trained.
I mean,
I couldn't have planned it better.
It's like four miles from my house.
And that's amazing.
In the middle of month.
Well not the middle of the northwest corner of Montana to have that there is
unbelievable.
How far are you from Bozeman?
Uh,
as the crow flies,
maybe 200 and some miles.
But the drive there is Leighton,
an l,
it's not straight.
It takes about six mountains.
Grizzly bears swerve past.
See any grizzlies since you've been moved there?
No,
no.
The fucking everywhere.
They're waiting for you.
Right.
I don't leave my house.
I just,
I don't like to really know,
just hanging out with myself and have conversations and go to Jujitsu.
But I'll do,
I do an hour and a lot of it is just drill base for that hour and then there's
an open mat afterwards.
Uh,
okay.
So I'm getting,
I mean I feel like I'm getting a good mix of both.
And for me,
I met the phase,
like I'm such in the alphabet face,
I'm like a r B like letters together and towards later.
And when I roll I just tell myself,
you know,
maybe just focus on the fundamentals.
You don't need to create new techniques and overrule.
That's true.
And I try to relax and use zero strength because I am bigger than most people
that are there and I don't.
I've heard enough times that if you rely on your attributes early on,
what's gonna end up happening is you'll have success early and then you're going
to nose dive because yes,
and so I'm just trying to go the other route.
Just be as calm as possible,
use as little as strength as possible and just tap early and tap off.
This is my favorite move.
Yeah.
Another good thing to do is work off your back because you're a big guy.
That's where I started.
I actually asked,
I said,
can you just teach me the worst position ever and I'll try to build up from
there and I don't care about offense.
I'd rather learn defense.
That's,
that's very intelligent of you.
That's something that a lot of people don't do and I certainly didn't do.
I was just trying to choke people quick like what could I,
what could I do?
I don't have much success,
chuck and me,
but if you can get really comfortable with your is the most important thing.
Like Hicks and Gracie's always said that he's like,
uh,
the most important things to be safe.
He's like,
I'm always safe.
It goes no matter where I'm,
what he would have Hixon would have real like high level black belts start on
his back with a fully locked in rear naked choke really.
And then he would defend and then he would always tap them.
I mean,
honestly to me that's like holding a 45 pound plate out,
letting go and it just hovers.
I mean I just beyond my understanding how they're able to do that.
Well there's levels,
you know,
there's levels to everything.
I miss eyeopening when I started,
I'm like,
Oh yeah,
I know,
right?
Like this is obviously a simple recipe.
Go to gym tat people out.
There's nothing in between.
I got this.
And then after like my first 20 minutes,
I'm like,
Oh shit.
It's humbling man.
Humble.
That's one of the best parts about it.
Like I love,
so my body tells me like,
I know who I'm going to have a really,
really tough role with and they're probably going to beat me and I can feel it.
Balancing against my ego,
but like my,
you know,
if I just go roll with that guy over there,
I bet she'll be successful and I feel that inherently and I'll just go roll with
the person I knew who was probably going to beat me because I love that choice
when something that protects your ego and something that keeps it in check
because it is,
it is humbling and I've been a dumb ass.
I should adapt earlier before and I'm sitting there,
they completely have me locked in,
but I'm going to try to muscle my way out of this and then my arm's sore for
three weeks.
Well,
it's actually important to do both.
Believe it or not.
It's important to be humbled for sure.
It's important to have a realistic perspective of your abilities,
but it's also important to tap people.
And so,
uh,
you know,
I was to tell people that like,
one of the best ways to get really good as a strangle blue belts,
get people that have like a little bit,
a little bit of technique and they have a little bit of understanding what's
going on and just put the choke to them and,
but also drilling.
But then you know,
you have to roll with people that are legitimately far better than you just to
for a perspective enhance or to understand how quickly someone can close the
distance,
how quickly someone can take advantage of an opportunity.
And,
and then also the,
the feeling of being set up to three steps in a row.
Like one of the things like when a role with uh,
John Jacques Machado is a,
you know,
he's multiple time world champion and you'll see like,
especially over time,
the many,
many,
many times of training with him,
you'll see he's setting you up several steps ahead if he's sweeping you to,
to the left,
right.
He's sweeping you this way.
He's expecting you to base.
Yeah.
And when you base,
he's going to adjust.
And when you adjust to him adjusting,
he's going to grab your leg and then boom,
you're on your back and you're like,
fuck yeah.
It's like he already saw the path and you're just all you're thinking of.
Oh,
don't let him sweep me.
Yeah.
But he's sort of trying to sweep you.
I mean,
if you just give in like a bitch,
he'll sweep you.
But he's really wanting you to base.
And then when you go to defend the base,
then he's going to trap you.
And then when you go to try adjust for the trap,
whoops,
he's got your leg and you're on your back,
and then his knees on your belly and you're like mother fucker.
And he saw the whole thing.
So many steps ahead.
I mean,
it's,
it's a beautiful art form.
It really is.
Because,
you know,
I always say like about,
uh,
the guys that I know that are like some of the best guys in the world,
there's so different than what you'd expect.
The really like nerd assassins.
Yeah.
Because they're really smart because you're thinking almost like a,
it's like kinetic chess.
You thinking about all these moves,
it's just that you can get your chess pieces to move better than other people's
chest pieces can.
It's like chess,
but you can make your chest if you do a lot of box jumps and pliers and you
know,
you,
you do heavy duty strength and conditioning routines.
You can get your chess pieces to move better.
You can get everything to,
you can give your chess pieces more endurance.
You can,
you know,
you can prolong your,
your,
uh,
ability to train and roll.
It's been great.
And like I said it,
you know,
in those moments where you're getting choked or I can't breathe,
like it's the same type of focus.
It is the singular goal in your life to not get murdered.
And I feel,
for me it's been crazy healthy.
I can't speak to the larger veteran community,
but I can absolutely say for me it's beneficial.
I think it's beneficial for a lot of veterans.
I talked to a lot of them that train and they've said that,
you know,
and a lot of gets super addicted.
You know,
they're,
they're there five,
six days a week and you know,
wrapping up their elbows and their risks and taping up their fingers and they
don't give a fuck.
They just want to keep going.
They'll literally roll like this with one arm cause their shoulders blown out.
I'm like,
you're not going to take time off.
I'm just going to work around it,
work around it,
which is not always good because eventually you there,
I know a lot of guys who've reached a point where there may be,
could've rehabbed something and now they have to have surgery because they've
kind of blown it out to the point where it's fucking dangling.
How much do you still role?
Very little.
Really?
Yeah.
I want to get into it.
I've had some significant injuries.
Um,
I really backed off a couple of years ago because I had,
um,
some bulging discs that were impacting my nerves and they were making my hands
hurt and my elbows hurt.
And it was,
uh,
my,
my neck had,
uh,
some bulging discs that were pressing against my nerves.
And uh,
I got Regena keen on that and I did some spinal decompression and a relieved all
that.
Then I tore some meniscus and I had some shoulder injuries.
The shoulder injuries?
Yeah,
the shoulder injuries where w really bothersome because it was also fucking with
archery and I was really worried about not being able to don't fuck with
archery.
Yeah.
I love it too much.
And so I rehabbed those almost 100%.
My left one is still a little wonky,
but I'm ready to roll.
I'm going to,
I'm going to train with John jock either this week or next week and we're going
to do a podcast.
So how I'll get back into it once,
once that happens.
So with,
when did you start Jujitsu?
96.
Okay.
So substantial period of time.
With that amount of time off that you essentially had to take,
what impact would that have for you?
It'll have a little bit of impact on my timing,
but luckily during this entire time I've worked out very hard.
Okay.
So my,
my body's physically in very good shape.
Like today.
Um,
I ran the mountains for the first time in like six weeks since my meniscus
injury and it seems to be 100%.
I mean,
maybe not 100%,
but no pain at all.
Um,
and I ran a good steep course where it's,
you know,
like heavy duty running in the,
in the hills and I was getting cysts,
like recurring cysts because that,
where the meniscus tear was,
there was some,
you know,
it was loose.
And so like as I'm pounding,
the blood would pull up and then it would swell up and I had to get it drained
and they'd stick this fucking fat needle in there and suck all this puss out.
It was nasty.
So I got exosomes and platelet rich plasma six weeks ago.
So from then,
um,
I waited,
uh,
the six weeks,
but during that time period I'd mostly did that echo bike.
Yeah.
That rogue echo bike,
cause it's not impactful so it doesn't put the pounding on the knee that that
was causing the cyst.
But fuck man,
does that thing build your cardio up?
It's designed by Satan.
It's amazing to Bottas 20,
2010.
Yeah,
20 seconds.
Sprint ten second rest.
Fuck.
Those are incredible.
That bike will give you everything that you are willing to take.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
It really well.
So I'm really pleased with myself that I didn't allow myself to get out of shape
because when I ran today I was like,
fuck,
it's been six weeks is going to be brutal.
It wasn't brutal.
It was normal because I've been doing the echo bike,
so it's maintained my cardiovascular level,
which was always my weakest point.
But,
and so your knowledge and experience base in Jujitsu.
And I ask,
because like I said,
I've been at this for six months.
I'll take a week off for travel and I'll go back to a class and I feel like I
have a massive disconnect between knowledge and getting my body to work.
And I suspect it's because I'm thinking too much.
Whereas like I was saying,
you,
you have the ability to listen to Miley Cyrus in your head or whatever her name,
Christina Aguilera.
I like Miley Cyrus to awesome
people are into weird shit.
I'm not going to put a value judgment on that.
Whereas I don't.
So for me,
if I take time off,
it's,
I really,
really struggle with it because I,
I can't connect the dots.
So it's definitely,
there's a difference though.
The pathways get sharper.
When I trained more,
like last time I was doing like serious training was over a year ago and when I
was doing it,
like after a few sessions the pathways sharpen and like,
you know,
will you clinch up,
there's less hesitation is more of an understanding of what's got to take place.
It's more of like a familiarity with training.
Yeah.
But you know,
as you get older,
you know,
I'm 51 now.
The thing that happens is you're fucking joints and your,
your body does not want to hold up to this continued stress.
So you have to really be careful about when to train and how hard you train.
Like my friend Eddie Bravo is going through that right now.
He has a a fake disc now and his lower back,
he had to have as a disc replaced with titanium articulating disc.
He had knee surgery,
he had shoulder surgery and he now he needs wrist surgery and now this is all
within like you know,
a couple of years and he's a couple years younger than me.
So his body is hitting that,
that point where this years and years and years of strain and poll and choke and
resist and Bass and written push and your body just doesn't want to do that all
the time.
So you have to be,
you have to be smart in terms of how much stress and how much recovery you put
on.
I think you also have to be really smart about working on your flexibility and
working on your recovery,
whether it's through cryotherapy or sauna use or massage.
But rest too.
You can't train like a fucking wild demon six days a week when you're 50 you
just can't.
You might get a couple of days in heart,
but you also have to understand like flow roles.
Yeah.
Phyllo rolls are giant.
It's the same thing with flow sparring.
Like I remember some of the best gains that I made as a kickboxer with training
with guys who I knew I could trust to not fucking brain me like that.
We would tap each other and so then you're carving pathways,
but you're not taking the kind of abuse that you take if you're just going to
cause sometimes sparring.
It's not really sparring.
You're fighting,
you're fighting people in the gym.
You just get together and you're,
you're lacing up your gloves,
your tap and gloves.
They say go,
the bell goes off and you're fucking full blasting each other.
And it's more common than not.
Especially in the early days.
I kind of find that to be the case with two white belts squaring off Sam,
cause you got to do the blood circle to make sure nobody's going to get hurt by
the fricking momentum bouncing around the gym.
It's like,
hey buddy,
you want to just work on that technique?
And they look at it and go,
uh Huh.
I'm like,
Oh fuck.
They're just trying to kill.
Yeah,
they're trying to kill you.
Yeah.
There's a lot of that is,
it's really uncomfortable when someone does that to you too.
You're like,
God damn it.
Do I have to do this with you?
You know,
like sometimes you could choke him quick and they'll calm down and sometimes it
just makes them more amped up in it.
Depending on the human.
I feel like you need to focus on my chokes now.
It's not my strength now.
Are you mostly going,
gee,
are you going near Nogi as well?
I do more geeky that Nogi only because it happens to work with my schedule.
So Monday's and Friday's I'd love doing,
uh,
or I have loved doing the Nogi stuff that I have because it's so quick and I
find that it rotate through a lot of the different positions and I find myself
working out of other problems more than I would and like a normal five minute
just to open role.
Um,
and I realize how limited my offenses cause I liked hold onto the pajamas and
write,
you know,
door basically hold on to fricking door knob on some of these color.
It makes sense to be now when I've heard you talking before like yeah,
go ahead and wear that sweatshirt now.
I'm like,
Ooh,
I don't want to wear someone wearing a tie somewhere at a time.
Like I'll kill you.
What?
That tie,
I get ahold of that tire.
A dead man.
You gotta a noose around your neck cause zip up Hoodie.
Oh yeah.
I'm like,
oh man.
First obviously I'd rub that zipper across your neck but then you're getting
choked with it.
Wow.
How about a leather jacket?
If you're fucking with someone in those in the street and that someone's a judo
player,
someone who knows judo and you got to like a thick ass winter coat and then your
Dab Brainu with the world.
What does drive your fucking head into the concrete?
It's been cool man.
I wish,
I wish I had found it earlier and I wish I hadn't been so hesitant to try it
earlier.
And the reason I was hundred percent reason I was is because of my own ego.
Yeah,
but the thing is it doesn't matter.
Like when I wish I had done it earlier,
fuck all that.
You're doing it now.
Like that's it's important.
Like it doesn't matter when you start the,
the thing about Jujitsu is once you're on a path,
just enjoy the path.
Don't think God,
I should have started when I was eight.
Well you can't unless you have a fucking time machine.
And if you did,
God damn it.
I would not want to go back and be eight years old and know everything I know
now.
And like,
it'd be like watching a movie for the 100th time.
Be bored out of your mind thought fuck it up.
I would probably wind up homeless.
Your snow,
your stock portfolio would be amazing because of all the noise be right like
apple,
these fuckers are going to figure it out by apple at three.
Let's get some Amazon stock going.
Like you kill it on that.
People would be like,
what a book thing.
An online book.
Think.
Trust me,
don't worry about it.
Put it all in there.
Put all your money on Facebook.
What's his Facebook fuck?
He talking,
you know David Cho,
uh,
he painted Facebook,
he did like murals for Facebook and their studio and they paid him in stock and
he got wow.
Fucking hundreds.
Hundreds means from that and he's just balling all over the world on his
Facebook stock.
They don't seem to be doing too well these days though.
Seeing them not to stock necessarily company.
I keep seeing them in the news for the wrong reasons.
Yes.
That's a really interesting point,
right.
You know,
I've been focusing a lot on like the,
what these people are doing in terms of social media and in terms of,
you know,
what impact this has on our elections,
on our culture,
how they're being influenced.
There's a woman,
do we,
we uh,
privacy?
Yeah,
we booked that woman,
right?
Renee W,
what is her last name again?
She's got a phenomenal podcast with Sam Harris called the war of information and
um,
let's see that the information war,
the war of information.
Doretta Rene de restaurant and she studied this,
um,
she studied these,
these Russian troll farms and the impact they have and these fake accounts
online.
And what they'll do is like for instance,
they set up to rallies across the street from each other.
One was a Texas pride rally and one was a Muslim Riley.
It's classic pairing and they do it across the street from each other on purpose
so that they'll interact with other so that people get there.
There's no one organizing it because no,
there's no real person on the ground because they're doing everything from
Russia.
And this is just one example.
They do a lot of with um,
with,
uh,
black lives matter and blue lives matter.
They were having a lot of these,
they were pairing them against each other.
They were also,
um,
they had,
uh,
black pages that were supporting anyone but Hillary,
this was their message.
Anyone but Hillary,
Hillary Clinton does not support the black community.
We should vote for Bernie Sanders.
We should vote for Jill Stein.
We should vote for anybody but Hillary.
And what they're basically trying to do was weak in the support that the
Democrats traditionally have from the black community.
And they were there doing this through these pages.
And there was not that many pages.
When you find out there's like 80 pages or a hundred pages they were running.
But then you find out the amount of interactions that they had within this
millions and millions and millions of interactions.
So comments,
likes,
shares,
and then people are this message that they think is coming from people from
their community has actually coming from Russia.
And it's actually a calculated attempt to sow dissent and does so the,
this conflict in America.
And the idea is,
and it sounded so crazy to me,
they like,
cause I wasn't really paying attention to it that much,
but the idea is that they're trying to make us fight against each other about
everything so that it fucks up democracy.
So the idea is to have achieved that goal.
Whether or not they're responsible for it or not,
but it certainly sends,
seems like we're trending in that direction.
It does.
I,
I can't remember a time where there's more conflict and more outrage and more
people willing to like jump into the fray regardless of whether or not they're
informed.
What do you think about the people who keep calling for violence?
It drives me crazy because it's people who don't understand violence.
I was going to say the same thing.
I see the people who most often doing it are the ones that are the least
experienced or familiar with what violence.
Actually it looks like there was a lot of that from Russia as well.
There's a lot of fake antifa pages.
There was a lot of that.
There was a lot of that where they were telling people that the only way to get
people to understand is to violence and that you must be willing to do whatever
you can by any means necessary.
And violence is good if it achieves the desired result of peace and prosperity
and making sure the progressive ideas get pushed forth.
It's fucking crazy because people who don't know what violence is,
it's like,
here's one thing that people say,
they'll say to a martial arts person,
like they'll see someone like a John Jones.
Like if I was John Jones,
I just fucking kick everybody's ass.
Like,
no you wouldn't.
No you wouldn't.
Okay.
You know,
and all the problems that Jon Jones has been in,
one thing you should notice is never been in a fight.
There's no street fights out there with John Jones.
You know what I mean?
I would bet he has least the least likely person to engage in that activity.
I bet you're right.
Yeah,
because he doesn't want to do it.
Cause he knows exactly the consequences,
let alone the legal consequences of doing it outside of a cage.
Exactly.
But when you look at it from someone who has zero understanding,
they were like,
Oh,
if I was that guy,
be kicking everybody's ass.
But no you wouldn't.
Because like violence,
people don't just accept violence.
You don't just hit someone and get away with it.
They think about that shit forever and they try to get you back and either hire
to get you back or they get you back on the own or they wait for you to not
remember it and then they,
they come around the corner and fucking brainy with a baseball bat.
This is what people do.
People don't like getting fucked up.
If you kick someone's ass,
they're going to remember it.
They're going to,
and this idea that you're going to be able to suppress people buy by attacking
them and hitting them with bike locks and you know,
and not letting them speak at universities that you know,
you're,
you're protesting at,
it's,
it's madness and it's,
it's so confusing because it's not indicative of what I always thought of when I
thought about left wing people.
I thought there were peace loving people or well educated and instead you're
getting these people that are from their fucking computer,
they're calling for violence.
Like you don't know what violence is
is too from what I've seen,
it didn't start with the bike locks,
right?
It started with,
you know,
shout this person down.
Yeah.
And then it's like fist fights and then they're throwing rocks and then it's
bike locks and now I hear people,
you know,
get your guns and it starts to rise to that level.
I'm like,
okay,
yeah,
you people need to calm down because the theory of it,
we need a revolution in this country.
You're like,
let's pump the brakes,
boy.
Right?
Yeah.
Well first of all,
here's what we need.
We need camaraderie.
We need to be nice.
This is more important than anything.
We need to be calm with each other.
You know this,
this idea that yelling people down stops anything.
You're just going to make people yell louder on the other side that that shit
does not work.
That's not how human beings operate when it,
if you want human beings to appreciate your perspective,
find the things that you agree on and work towards a better humanity,
work towards a better,
more loving way of interacting with each other.
This is possible while disagreeing,
and this is one of the most important things I think that we could ever express
in terms of how to communicate with each other.
You don't have to shout people down like the,
the best way to do it is to try to figure out the points that you can agree on.
Find out what you disagree on and find out why you disagree on it and you're
always going to get bad actors,
right?
You're always going to get people that are in there that they don't care.
They're not reasonable,
they just want to win and there's a giant problem with that kind of
communicating because it's so absolute.
It's my way or the highway,
like that's,
that's where violence comes from.
That's where that's where real.
Yeah.
That's where real physical conflicts,
that's where they come from.
When there's no way to negotiate,
there's no way to communicate outside of that.
I just think it's,
I dunno,
bizarre is not the right word.
I think it's sad that the vast majority from,
again,
my opinion,
what I see is people who are identifying with shit you can see on a street sign.
Yeah.
Like left or right,
right,
right.
You're telling me that as a species,
that's his nuances.
We can get,
you want to completely define yourself and your ideology and your beliefs by
something literally you can see just driving your car,
turn left,
turn right.
It's just,
I don't understand it.
I don't,
um,
it's the exact opposite world.
It to go back to,
you know,
getting out of the military and,
and,
and just kind of entering into the world like what's going on.
Yeah.
Makes no sense to me.
It makes me extremely uncomfortable.
I hate hearing people calling for violence.
Um,
I know,
and especially calling for violence when it's not necessary against the
Americas.
When you,
what you had to deal with in the military has to be the most intense form of,
of conflict that's available on planet earth.
The most intense form of conflict is war.
That's the real conflict.
That's real consequences.
You've suffered them physically,
you've seen countless friends offer them physically.
That's the real shit.
So when you seeing people from universities from these coddled environments and
these,
these people with it really an completely ignorant perspective as the,
as to what the actual consequences of violence are calling for it,
it's just bananas.
On one hand,
I'm glad that they haven't experienced it because I can tell that they haven't,
just by the way that they're acting and um,
I'm glad that they didn't have to do that.
But on the other one,
it's a tough pill to swallow because
I just don't unders.
War War is a,
uh,
it's about as high consequence as you can get for sure.
Like I said,
it resets your,
it resets your perspective.
And the last thing that I would ever want to see is that here on the streets of
the u s like I,
I just,
I can't even imagine how destructive,
well it would just,
it would destroy our country for sure.
But I also don't,
I can't figure out and the route out of where we are.
So people are calling for violence,
right.
And got other countries trying to incite it,
get groups together.
Like what's the navigatable route out of that?
Mushrooms.
Okay.
I had one Sittard that route.
The only way,
I don't know,
I honestly don't know.
Um,
I'm hoping that things don't have to come to a head.
I'm hoping that we don't have a Kent state or some,
some horrible event in this country were,
you know,
protesters and,
and the people that oppose them get into some horrible deadly violent encounter
cause so far other than Charlottesville,
that time that guy ran over a,
that woman did the car.
We're seeing most of this violence being at least somewhat contained to
fisticuffs.
Right.
And you know the,
the professor to hit that guy with a bike lock and there's a few other instances
of people getting knocked out and punched and hit with sticks.
We haven't seen mass shootings and murder,
but God dammit,
that Shit's clothes.
It's,
especially when you're doing rallies and people are like,
you know,
yeah,
let's do an open carry rally and everybody show in their operators sheikh
apparel with,
I looked at it,
the
pictures of that.
I'm like,
okay,
you have a lot of stuff.
First off,
that's on fucking backwards.
You know,
like I'm looking,
I'm like,
okay,
you have all the tools,
but you obviously don't practice with them.
But the danger of just,
you know,
what's the next step?
First,
we're just gonna,
you know,
we're going to where?
All of our stuff.
All right,
well if it started at fist and then went bike locks and then when show up with
your civil war gear,
right.
What's the next step after that shooting?
Yeah.
I mean,
I don't know.
I don't want to get involved in that.
I mean I,
well you picked a good spot where you're at in Montana where I live does not
suck.
Yeah.
Hang out there and either move in once the first few rounds have been fired,
the dust starts to settle.
I just
RAAM is,
I would want to come off the bench,
which of course the problem is,
is if that happens and I'm not,
I guarantee you I'm not the only one that feels like that.
I'm going to get involved and it's going to be a serious problem for those
individuals because,
uh,
I'd give my military career,
see across the board average,
there's absolutely nothing spectacular about my career.
I had done more than some way less than others,
but I've sacrificed enough that I'm not going to allow those people to tear us
apart.
But it's the last thing on earth that I want to do.
But they put me in that position.
I know that myself and many other people are in that same boat are going to get
involved and that's,
I don't know if that's going to help the problem,
but it's going to get ugly pretty fast.
I just don't remember a time where the country spins.
So divided in terms of,
I mean,
I don't know whether it's because of social media and because of the Russian
influence on social media compounded with having Trump as a president,
compounded with,
I mean people that feel like they're disenfranchised and they,
they don't feel like they're like,
you know,
you hear about this all the time in regards to income inequality.
People feel disenfranchised.
They feel like the system has failed them.
And that's why so many young kids are favoring socialism and why so many young
kids or are moving towards that.
They think that anything has got to be better than watching these fat rich cats
with all this money controlling the world.
And that the only way to get out of that as revolution,
but damn,
you're,
you know,
like there's a lot of people that are not those fat rich cats.
You're positioning yourself against it or just normal regular Americans who
happen to be conservative,
you know,
in conservative does not always have to equal racist.
It doesn't always have to equal white supremacy.
It doesn't always have to equal all the negative connotations,
you know,
religious fanaticism and all these different things that people always attach
towards conservatism.
It doesn't have to mean that it couldn't,
it could just mean people who are prudent with their finances,
who are,
you know,
they're,
they're cautious with the way they think.
They're,
they're more conservative in their values and their ideals.
This is theirs.
That's not a bad thing necessarily,
but we've got it lumped into these two groups left versus right.
And there's very little gray area.
It's the tyranny of war.
Yeah.
You know,
it's like,
it's as if there's only two choices.
You're either left or right.
Yeah.
Where's the end?
Where's you trend to the left?
And you also have some values that are associated with the right.
Yeah.
Or you're Tryna I that it's a,
I think we need to evolve,
you know,
I think we need to evolve the way we communicate with each other.
First off.
And I think there's so much of so much yelling on social media that people
engage in on a daily basis.
I mean,
I jumped into these little social media spats and watch these people going back
and forth with each other and like,
how do you live your life that has gotta be so stressful?
You're,
you've gotta be fucking freaking out every time you check your phone,
you know who's calling you a cock and who's,
you know,
who's giving out your home address and who's,
what kind of crazy shit or people doing.
It's so nuts right now.
I'm glad I'm late to the game on that stuff.
Like so late if I just,
so I have two teenage boys and a 10 year old girl and we've had some social
media issues with them.
If I grew up with the tools that they have,
I would not be sitting here with you today.
If I had had when I was 15 the ability to broadcast my idiotic thoughts to the
world,
I would be like,
I can't,
I tell my kids too,
I'm like,
you guys are growing up in a time in my opinion is,
is so much more difficult than the time I grew up in.
Agreed.
If I had a problem with you and be like,
Joe,
I would talk shit to your face.
Or I'd had to find out what your phone number is or mail you a letter,
a letter,
which would have been,
then by the time I showed up,
I wouldn't be pissed at you anymore.
So it would defeat the purpose.
I mean,
I've seen it firsthand,
you know,
responding to stuff.
People,
they're just watching and then they dive in and you know,
and like screen grabs.
Yup.
Next thing you know,
I'm at school x,
like help.
Hello Mr. Stone power.
He would like to show you this.
I'm like,
oh my God.
Oh my God.
But I get it at the same time.
Right.
And I recognize the language that they're using.
I'm like,
Oh yeah,
that was me,
but I was just talking to you.
Right.
You right.
I don't know how to,
it's a very difficult for me.
You got to come in and actually I think your daughters are younger than my sons.
It's rough.
Yeah,
it is rough.
And it's something that no one has done before.
Here's the thing,
like if you're in your forties or in your 50s or whatever and you have a kid
today,
you haven't done that.
You didn't grow up with the Internet.
The Internet didn't even exist until I was a grown man.
You know,
I mean I didn't get online until I was in my late twenties that's when it,
that's when it existed.
And these kids that are 10 and 11 they have phones already and they have
snapchat accounts and there,
you know,
and then there's,
one of the craziest ones,
his kids taking naked pictures of each other.
Cause this girl got arrested for child pornography.
Yup.
Cause she was taking pictures of her hoo ha and sending it to boys.
And she was 15 and so they were,
they were arresting her for distribution of child pornography.
And I'm like,
Hey,
hey,
stop with the fucking word of the law.
You assholes.
Do you really think this girl is a child?
Pornographer cause she's,
no,
she's us slot.
This is,
we grew up with kids like this.
Sorry.
I don't mean to slut shame,
but I mean for lack of a better term,
you know,
for comedic intent,
I had to use that word.
She's just a young girl was probably misguided.
But the point is,
we all knew girls like that and for whatever reason had this desperate need for
attention.
They just didn't have a platform.
Yeah,
they would just flash you their tits in the hallway or something like that.
I mean,
there was always girls that would do never had that happen.
We never had that happen.
No.
I knew girls that would do that.
It was always like,
you're east coast guy though.
I was the west coast guy.
They're different over there.
I would have to assume so given we don't have the same shared experience,
I think they're more savage on the east coast because they're the children of
immigrants,
you know,
or the grandchildren of immigrants.
And this is my,
my theory on this is my take on America in terms of immigration.
Right.
It's like the people that moved here from somewhere else,
they moved here from Europe,
been there.
There were wild fuckers who was like,
you know what,
I don't have a picture of this place.
I,
there's no youtube video for me to watch,
but I'm going to take a chance and I'm gonna get in a fucking boat with my
family.
I'm going to travel across a goddamn ocean for weeks and then I'm going to get
to their side.
And they're all in these weird communities of people.
Like,
you know,
my grandfather would always talk about how racist people were against Italians.
And then there's the,
there was a lot of that went against Irish and all these like immigrant
communities on the east coast.
And then what happens is they would get in their car and they would go,
fuck this place,
let's go west.
And they would keep going until they got to California.
And I think that's why California is like one of the most progressive places
because it's the furthest away from where people landed.
So the people that wanted to get the fuck away from them,
they got as far away as they could and the even smarter ones came to Montana.
And then there's some people in the middle.
They went,
why are we,
why are we traveling?
Just stop right here.
Especially like you go to places like,
I mean there's a lot of places that are fucking amazing that are like in the
middle flyover states here mean,
you know,
you call it flyover states,
but I mean there's a lot of great spots in Texas.
You know,
you go to Austin,
you go,
okay,
why are we moving?
Yeah,
why don't we just stay right here?
This is fucking great.
Like,
do we really need to go to Santa Monica?
No,
you can stay right here.
San Antonio is pretty cool too.
I was down there with deadly,
uh,
twice in the last month and it's like pretty cool town.
I've never been,
it's a little,
I shouldn't say talent.
I think it's the eighth largest city in the United States.
But is it really San Antonio is pretty sure.
Yeah.
Wow.
That's crazy.
I did not know that.
We think about it.
You don't know Jamie?
Jamie's dammit.
I was told it was the eighth largest San Antonio President and mayor.
No,
actually Evan from black rifle,
they have,
they go head of tourism for San Antonio.
I think San Antonio is like the fourth in Texas.
So it's like Dallas is number one,
probably Houston,
Austin,
San Antonio,
so forth in Texas.
That doesn't really make sense that it would be eighth in the country.
I think it might be with like actual size,
like Oh,
like land.
That's exactly what I meant.
Oh,
I'll get it.
I get it.
So Alaska is the biggest state in the country in terms of distance that you
could travel.
Have you been there much?
Alaska we go there or they will.
Last time I was there,
I had some interesting experiences is actually the last time I was there.
Uh,
that's where we do our cold weather training.
So only times I've been there it was for work,
which I had fun,
but it was also not enjoyable.
At the same time.
Those are real savages.
Those people live around wild animals.
Yes.
There's only like a hundred of them,
you know,
we would go to legit Kodiak island with Jamie as far as population isn't really
damn yes.
1,469,000 so it's actually bigger than you thought.
Well,
it's bigger than Phoenix.
That's bigger than San Diego.
Just under Phoenix.
Oh,
Phoenix is six.
I see.
That's crazy.
It's just we're just under fucking,
it's just past Philly.
Philly's number five after Houston.
That's nuts,
man.
There's more than 1.5 million people in Philly though.
That doesn't seem right.
This number for San Diego seemed very low as well.
Yeah,
I thought it was in the threes.
I don't know what they're counting.
Actually this,
I just googled it assholes.
Top largest city for assholes and number one cause is only 8 million.
What?
Los Angeles.
Okay.
Shut your fucking mouth.
Los Angeles,
3,900,000 Los Angeles has 20 million people and who knows how many Mexican
folks,
they don't have any idea how many people have snuck across the border.
They literally have no idea.
Yeah,
it's just pure guesswork.
Like what?
Who's doing these censuses and who were they talking to?
Like why would they have traffic cameras that are judging based on the amount of
cars that are driving past them every day?
They don't really know.
I think it's a guess.
It's a fucking guests.
They probably have one place where they have a video camera up where they can
capture a certain amount,
multiply it by a magnitude,
and then extrapolate that over.
Like,
I don't know.
Actually it's probably scientists.
They're probably pretty good at guessing republic retarded.
I don't know on that.
Shouldn't use that word.
I think our,
our,
our take on it though is,
is really essentially based on,
you know,
like what,
who's,
how many people are registered in this area,
how many people we absolutely know and then how many people have pushed into
this area from other places.
Like how,
what's up size?
It's the number 38 TV market somehow.
So I don't know what else,
Antonio.
Oh,
so I don't know how it fits in that number that way.
It's,
it's very strange how they're accounting TVS.
They've moved past TVs.
Maybe they're just reading books was,
maybe it was number one for book reading.
I'm going to go out on a limb and say,
that's not the case.
Well,
it's,
you know,
I don't know,
man.
It's,
it's,
it's an interesting thing like population because when you fly over the country,
you look down and go,
wow,
look at all that spot that people could live in.
Like,
are we really overpopulated?
You know,
but then in certain areas and then others not so much.
Well,
in others you just fly over.
There's nothing there forever.
Like I drove from Vegas to La and there's some spots you drive from Vegas to la
where as you're driving,
you go,
okay,
what the fuck is here?
Like what,
who are these people that live in these we little Nevada,
a towns that are off of the 15,
not even the town's ban.
So I used to fly a bunch from San Diego out to Prescott and then kind of do that
loop.
Uh,
have a sue in like the Vegas area.
Miles from anything.
Double wide trailer.
Yeah,
just,
just a sterile roads single.
But then at the same time you could,
cause you're,
you know,
you're higher up,
you can see the geometric patterns.
Like it's just chunks of squares and there's two double wides five miles away.
Like I don't know,
sand people.
Yeah.
I saw one where this guy had this set up and they had a fence around his house
and then he had a fucking antenna,
like one of them big ass ham radio antennas.
Yeah.
He's just talking to aliens.
Just communicating or fellow alien researchers who are out there looking for,
yeah,
I have a,
I'd rather go into houses overseas that make entry into that man's house.
Yeah.
Probably less pathogens,
less less likely to get banged up to the star ship enterprise to got to write
that too.
I just wonder like how a person winds up in that double wide trailer miles away
from Barstow.
Like how do you like what path you get from being a baby coming out of your mom
a vagina to one day,
be an hold up sniffing bath salts,
you know,
smelling your own farts thinking.
Nailed it.
Yeah.
Counting how many bullets you have in case the aliens come to get you.
Unfortunately,
I find a lot of those people either have a lot of guns or a lot of bullets,
but not both at the same time.
You'd be surprised how many,
it's like,
wow,
you have a lot of guns.
Where's your ammo?
I ain't got a box of it over there.
I'm like,
okay,
that's cool.
It's so much to do like a trailer park tour of this country.
Just like for a documentary.
Just what happened?
How'd you get here?
Like is it,
was your family from here?
Like this is not a good community.
We gotta get you Outta here.
Yeah.
What's your escape plan?
Which was gonna escape place.
You're 200 miles away from the nearest city.
You're surrounded by desert and you have a trailer out here.
Like what's going on,
man?
I always think about where do you go for groceries and how often you eat rabbits
that you find your backyard sometimes.
Probably like,
dude,
if you went to the grocery store,
he came back.
Damn it,
I forgot the milk.
Yeah.
Final Havoline and suck his dick that this is not a solid picture option.
Have you been to Alaska much?
I've only been a few times.
Where did you go?
Went to anchorage.
We uh,
me and Ari Shaffir it did some salmon fishing.
Had a great time doing that.
And then we did two shows up there and then I've been a hunting,
uh,
on Prince of Wales.
Uh,
we did some,
um,
Sitka,
Sitka deer hunting,
Barksdale tail Barklow from Sitka ran not when I went through,
but he ran the cold weather facility on Kodiak island.
Oh,
okay.
15 years.
Kodiak can go fuck itself with those damn gigantic
huge,
humongous bears.
Oh,
that's why I'm saying we had some interesting experiences.
That's where we did our cold weather training.
Did you run into bears?
There are always bears around,
but also having a machine gun helps with that.
So that does make you feel bad.
It makes you feel better,
but not when you're sleeping at night.
Ooh.
We camped.
We would do snow shoe like just deep into the back.
So we had,
we would go and do,
you had to do your cold weather training.
So getting your dry suits on and swimming through the surf at nighttime.
Wonderful.
Which is an ice cream headache over and over and over again as the ocean breaks
over your head.
It's pretty bad.
Uh,
and the cold weather,
uh,
immersion tests is there where you have to get into the water but just a pair of
shorts on for five minutes and just then rewarm yourself.
So they get you to a point of hypothermia right to the edge.
It's,
I think,
uh,
as many things are in my old job,
there is a aspect of learning and there is an aspect of tough it out and you
combine the two.
So it,
it sucked.
And there was,
there was a reason that they wanted it to suck,
but they're also trying to teach a lesson.
Right.
But God forbid they just teach the lesson.
So they make you suffer to ingrain it probably.
Yeah.
So one day you wake up and on the board,
like a little whiteboard that has the list of gear you need.
It just says shorts running shoes.
I'm like,
okay,
this is February and Kodiak,
what are you talking about?
Literally I said,
said shorts running shoes.
Get out in the Ford ICAN align van.
So we all get out there and they drive to the beach where seawater is freezing
at the edge and they say,
okay,
go out.
You have to completely submerge yourself neck deep water,
five minutes and the timer starts,
the timer starts when the last person submerges their head.
Oh God.
So you might be first,
you might be able,
you can't rush off,
be all fired up and it,
you're just going to get seven and a half minutes is what you're getting.
So you go and you sit there and it's the cold,
it hurts for a minute and then you're numb.
The worst thing about it actually has rewarming.
It feels like you're just getting pin pricked over and over and over again.
Yes.
That's actually a bark low.
Oh,
that is Barklow look at him standing up there on that rock will Barklow has a
great rewarming drill that we actually played on the podcast before for Sitka
where he takes their gear and jumps into a lake.
So that is the timber.
Yeah.
And then re warms himself with basically all sit cause gear and figures out how
to get your body back to what I thought was interesting that I never really
considered those,
that eating food actually ramps up your body heat because you have to burn off
the calories,
your body starts processing.
The food actually is good for elevating potty temperature,
eating food,
especially if you can get hot food of course.
But just eating.
So the drill,
the drill he was doing actually had much more,
uh,
I would say educational benefit because they would make them,
they would take them there with all of their gear,
their gearless would say whatever they were wearing,
plus bring your tent,
your sleeping bag and all your stuff because we're going to put you into the
water and then you need to survive your way out of it so that they would,
they would have to erect a tent.
They would have to get their sleeping bag out all after being in the water for
five minutes,
which is exactly what a survival situation is going to look like for us.
We went in there,
got back into the van and I sat in a hot tub and drank beer for the rest of the
day.
So I got the understanding of what it feels like to be hypothermic and that just
see they have to push their head underwater.
Woo.
That guy right there is either screwing everybody or was the first person to
complete it.
Um,
now Wim Hoff does so much of this cold water submersion stuff and he actually
enjoys it.
And loves it,
you know?
Do you think that there's a way that you could use like his methods and get
through that with less pain potentially.
Even though you know,
all of the skills that I used in Kodiak,
I,
I did not ever use a single one of them.
Operationally I use his breathing method in the Cryo tank.
That makes sense.
Therapy.
But that art does Arctic conditions,
I don't know,
at least in the modern theaters of war were engaged in,
I don't know where the applicability would be.
So it might be a little bit of a benefit versus time expended to teach the guys
that stuff.
Hmm.
You know,
because unless it's a,
we're talking like Korea probably farther in the northern latitudes.
I mean it's uh,
like the training was amazing.
Like I said,
I didn't use a single bit of it.
Right.
But if something,
well,
it's also building mental toughness and determination and that's why I said
there's an aspect of learning and there's an aspect of just this is going to
suck.
Right?
Hey,
you guys,
guess what?
You're going to do a 20 kilometer hike into the back country and snow snowshoes.
There is no end state to this.
You,
there's no target.
You're going to do anything on,
you're just going to go out there and you're gonna do it and you're gonna
survive out there and it's going to suck for three days and then you're gonna
come back.
You just embrace this side or you learn how to pack your backpack better,
you know,
or you learn how to move better over that terrain are you learn how to navigate
in that environment.
So there's always an essence of it,
but it just happens to be that there's usually a pain component with it as well.
Yeah.
A lot of military training is like that.
There's an essence of a pain compliance and then the actual learning technique
as well.
Yeah,
it's the,
the learning technique.
I mean,
it is really,
you're,
you're learning a technique to manage your mind under sucky conditions credit.
That is a technique as well.
Right?
So I was actually having a conversation with somebody about this recently.
Uh,
I'm of the opinion that really the only thing that I learned how to do when I
was a seal was to enhance my ability to learn other things.
It's you're selecting for people and and to get to that point,
you've got to maintain control of your emotions,
whether you're in pain or you're hot or you're cold.
So there's that,
that essence of self control,
but then they require so many different skill sets in so many different things
that the selection process is looking for and then at the end of it,
teaching people how to become better learners and then you just refine that over
and over and over again over a career.
It's the ability to learn is probably the biggest takeaway that I have from my
time in service.
I think that's the best thing you could ever really learn is learning how to
learn,
learning how to learn correctly,
learning how to actual,
pay attention to what someone's teaching you and absorb it and follow the steps
rather than fuck it up with your own ego and your own insecurities or whatever
it is.
It's going to trip you up.
If you can get good at something,
you know you can,
you can apply that to almost anything if you really focus.
Yeah.
And,
and then they would pair it with,
we'll surround you by,
okay.
We want to make you better at shooting.
So we are going to go find world champion,
pistol carbine shooters.
Go apply your ability to learn with them.
And we would do it for weeks.
Okay.
Now you're going to specialize.
You're going to be appointment,
so you need to be able to navigate and climbs.
So we're going to send you out to Joshua tree for two weeks with worldclass
climbers.
Go apply your ability to learn with them and then jumping and then diving and
then tactics,
and then fill in the blank over a career.
That's another thing that freaks me out.
It's climbing.
Did you do much climbing?
I was a lead climber up until the point where I don't have a use of my ankle
anymore because of the nerve injury.
Oh.
And it's funny as I'm actually,
I don't like heights.
Did you free solo at all?
Uh,
as long as I wasn't more like thin three feet off the ground.
Yes,
I'm totally comfortable free soloing and moving laterally it but not vertically
away from the ground.
Cause I,
oh my God,
I watched it maybe three times in a row.
And here's the thing,
I know he's alive.
I know he was on your podcast.
I listened to it.
And in the final scenes I realized I was sitting there white knuckling my
recliner,
like my hands were sweating and I'm like,
I know he lives but it's still freaked me the fuck out.
Wow.
I mean that guy.
Yeah,
he's something.
But you know what's interesting about climbing as you get,
the more exposure you have,
the less it bothers you.
Like I uh,
so lead climbing is interesting,
especially if you are placing your protection as you go.
If it's drilled in both saying league or lead Lea d like lead.
Like if someone's in front of you,
you're well a rope.
As a lead climber,
you are probably setting the ropes.
At least in my old job,
you're setting the ropes for the people who are going to follow them.
Okay.
Most of the time when you see people what not most of the time,
but one of the disciplines would be,
there's bolted routes that go up a rock.
So you can just bring,
you know karabiners and put the Caribbean or through that and you loop the rope
through it and you're good to go.
Another aspect would be is you don't use the bolt bolted in stuff and you
basically carry on your climbing harness,
a rack of gear.
So as you're holding onto the rocks,
you're trying to wedge a block or a stopper in or a cam system that it rotates
to be smaller than as you release it opens up and if you pull against it,
it locks itself into the rock.
So you're setting your own protection and how much do you trust those things?
So that was the point that I was getting too.
Sometimes you get to a place and you're like,
this is the perfect piece of gear.
And of course you're always like six feet off the ground when the perfect piece
of gear.
And then you'll get multi pitches up in the air,
should be two,
300 feet up in the air.
And you're a lead climber.
So there's nobody above you and you're setting your own pro and you're starting
to get emotionally involved in the situation that you're in.
And you set a piece of pro and it's,
it's rattling around a little.
So I don't know were,
we don't know how good that one's going to be,
but we're going to keep climbing.
And then the next piece of pro,
you said not the most awesome piece because you're worried about the one beneath
you and you don't want to fall.
So you get it in there and then you just keep climbing.
So sometimes it's awesome and sometimes it's terrifying.
And then you got to think that if you do fall,
all that force,
if one pops and then the second one pops your,
you've got a lot of distance,
we get to think it's double the distance.
If you're 10 feet above the last piece of protection you put in,
you follow the 10 feet to the protection,
then the 10 feet past the protection,
clink,
and then it pulls on the PR on the pro.
So it's actually double the height that you are above it.
It's not,
I've been probably more scared out of my mind actually.
The securities scares I've ever been as a,
you were lived in Boulder,
right?
Yeah,
there's a climb.
They're called the Biz steel crack.
It's in one of the national parks.
And I was there with a buddy and it was just me and him and a worldclass
climber.
And I was at the East Coast Command at the time.
So budget was no option.
I had the newest shiny and stuff.
I'm like taking plastic off of climbing gear to go climb this rock.
This guy pulls up in a van with a Marlboro hanging out and you know,
tennis shoes that have laces probably on one of the,
one of the,
one of the shoes and a and an old pair of pants.
And he's climbed every mountain ever.
So it's me and my buddy were climbing our way up.
I'm leading this pitch,
so you switched.
One guy will climb,
he sets an anchor,
the other person comes up and they pick all the protection out so you can just
switch and then the other person leads the way on the next one.
So I'm like halfway up this pitch and I can't move because I'm losing my shit.
I'm like 15 feet above the last piece of protection that I just put in.
I'm convinced that I feel my feet slipping off of the rock I'm holding.
I had my hand jammed into the rock and then you make a fist to like prevent it
from falling out.
You can actually see Alex doing that in free solo as he's climbing up those
slide their hand in and then they'll manipulate the shape.
So it pulls and as I'm,
my world is collapsing on me and I'm just sitting there.
I've got full sewing machine leg just sitting there and just shaking.
I hear voice just over my shoulder.
He's like,
hey man,
just put the piece of pro right there.
And I look over and this professional climber is right next to me with no rope
in his fucking tennis shoes,
smoking a cigarette,
which is what he was using to point to where I should have placed the next piece
of protection.
Cool,
calm and collected.
And I almost fell off the rock cause he scared me so bad.
I was so freaked out of what he was doing that I almost fell.
I'm like,
you need to get away from me immediately.
He's like,
yeah,
no problem.
Just scurried up the Rock in tennis shoes,
tennis shoes,
tennis shoes.
But you're not supposed to use tennis shoes.
I don't think it mattered.
I think the guy like he was partial complete monkey.
He just,
when you're around worldclass climbers,
I mean they can hang on an edge that is like a couple of pieces of paper and
this and the steel crack is not a difficult
route.
So I'm sure there was one right next to it and he just,
as I'm freaking out,
he's just sitting there just hey buddy.
And I didn't know he was there.
I literally almost fell off because he talked to me smoking a cigarette.
Yeah,
he was Ashen.
Put a piece of pro right here.
Get away from me.
Different kinds of heat,
but I guess that's one of those things where it's like exposure better at it.
You just,
yeah,
after a week of climbing,
you will not feel bad about walking up to the edge and just standing there.
Alex Honnold was telling us a story about one time it was free soloing and he
was halfway up and he,
well he was in the middle of this journey up this fucking mountain.
He realized he didn't bring any powder so it didn't have any chalk with them.
So his hands are sweating and he's just climbing within the,
with no powder.
So he met a guy halfway up these guys that were using ropes and you know,
they were doing it the right way and he's doing it with no ropes.
And he goes,
Hey man,
can I borrow your chalk?
And it,
it gives him a chalk bag and he goes,
I'll leave it for you at the top of the mountain.
So he takes a chalk bag,
passes these guys.
See Ya.
Yeah.
Just keeps going and then leaves the bag for the guy at the top of the hill.
I'm like,
what in the fuck man.
How could you start something like that.
Like an apparently said that once you start climbing you are committed to
climbing the climbing.
Yeah.
Fuck a hook.
That there's not enough money in the world that would make me attempt to stuff
that he does.
And if I was a climber that had,
if I was like,
you know,
feeling like I'm kicking ass on man,
tell my hand sweaty filming him just talking about it.
I sweat like a pig.
I'm telling,
I was watching it,
white knuckling and if I was a climber and he passed me and was like,
Hey,
do you mind if I borrow your Chuck Chuck?
I would finish that climb and never climb again.
Yeah.
Because I would realize that I am a complete and utter bitch in comparison to
what he is like if that's what's possible and I'm sitting here like struggling,
I'm like I'm out.
You're also built wrong for it.
I think the thin wire,
he guys,
it's the way to go.
He also has like these gorilla meds.
Yes.
Fingers man.
His fingers would just use to career just grabbing.
But he also said that he had gone through a series of injuries for the first
time in his life,
like recently over the last few years.
Yeah.
That was in the movie actually.
Uh,
like a compression of his disks and then a really bad strain on his ankle.
And he was talking to take six months off since we just started climbing in a
cast.
So it's a different kind of human.
I mean,
he also lives out of a van.
I mean he's world famous guy who's living in a van traveling around it,
just fucking climbing rocks.
Did you have him on after he had completed that climb?
Like they were.
Okay.
So he had been successful and they were just probably editing the project I had
them on earlier,
like years ago.
Yeah.
And then I had them on again recently.
Okay.
Yeah.
It's,
uh,
the guy I would want to talk to is Jimmy Chin,
the,
the photographer who is capturing all that.
Oh,
he's up there with them.
Right.
That's the,
that's the thing I would want to,
when he talks about it a little bit more so in the promos for the film,
but the,
how sketched out he was to actually be involved and sit there and film and how
much of a burden he felt to like stay out of the periphery and not engage,
get engaged in the headspace and make Alex do something different because the
cameras were there.
That would of course cost him his life.
Right.
I can't imagine the pressure of doing that or just,
I wouldn't do it.
Like if a buddy of mine was like,
Hey,
will you come fill me?
Uh,
you know,
freeze.
I,
I would say no because that would be so afraid of just watching them peel off.
Can imagine if you were up there filming and you wash the guy fall,
that would be rough.
And there are,
of course good friends and we have the sky.
Yeah.
This dude is savage and he's got his hands on the camera only.
Well he's got,
he's got a bunch of stuff,
so we see his foot.
His left foot is in,
he's kind of sick gays kind of secure down there.
He's got that care beaner.
He's got one going to his harness is actually,
you've got two ropes going to his harness,
so he's kind of angled and there's like a triangle,
but he's a world class climber in and of himself.
We also has a giant ass camera bag.
Look at that big ass bag hanging from his hip.
Look at that position he's in to,
oh fuck all this Jimmy.
So that's how they get it.
That's how they get into position for a lot of it.
He's jus marring.
Instead of climbing the rock,
he's got basically a senders that will lie to push it up and then they lock on
the rope.
So he's got one leg in there in one arm and he's kind of Giumarra.
We use those a lot of the times as well.
But he's a world class climber in and of himself.
I can kind of think you'd have to be right in order to be able to capture that.
The other team that I think they put together was like five to seven worldclass
guys,
but there's a movie of him called Ma.
Yeah,
no thanks.
What does that,
what does that guy doing?
He's hanging probably 3000 foot over nothing focusing on capturing the shot.
I would be focusing on the urine streaming down my leg.
Oh my God.
Soaking your socks.
Oh God.
Like I couldn't do that,
but I could go to the edge of that cliff and zip up my suit.
Absolutely no problem.
And send that off there and I bet you he would want no piece of that.
It's so bizarre.
Yeah.
If he shouldn't.
Alex,
who's shooting him to?
Good question.
Is there a third prayers down?
Mike Gill in the ski shooting,
Jimmy in the free Solo Millie,
I think they had a team of like five to seven people they had,
so they had long lens.
They had people up there,
they had remote cameras.
I mean it's a whole,
they obviously had drones flying around.
Well,
there was a film that,
you know,
besides this film,
the recent documentary,
which is a thing,
it's called Solo,
right.
A presale though before that,
there was also a late night one of those new shows like ABC world news tonight
or something like that.
They did a whole piece on him and they had this one guy who was a,
you know,
world class climber instead.
It's not a matter of if it's a matter of when he,
every
innovator in the wingsuit world yeah.
Is Dead.
Yeah.
It's uh,
I mean,
but at the same,
I say that I would totally agree with that,
but I also understand why he's doing it.
I mean,
the end state for all of us is pre determined and I would suspect having never
talked to the guy that he would rather meet his end like that then at 80 years
old as a geriatric.
Yeah.
I would imagine.
Wait,
but that doesn't ease the burden on the people around them.
And that's the,
that's the piece that was the toughest for me,
uh,
when it came to a wingsuit base jumping him there.
It's insane.
What is wrong with that man.
But meanwhile,
he's such a nice guy.
When you talk to Alex in real life,
he's a sweetheart.
He just,
you your root for him to quit.
Like,
look man,
you already did it.
Stop.
I have yet to hear him express desire to do so though.
He's not quitting.
You know?
I mean,
I don't know man.
Everybody's built different.
That's the thing,
you know?
Yeah.
We're all not I,
I want to be physically,
I mean,
the way your brain ticks,
everyone just has a different thing going on,
you know?
I mean,
what leads you to what you do?
Like what,
what is it about you?
Sometimes you look at your path in life and you'd like to where you are right
now and your,
what the fuck led me to be in this spot where I'm 2000 feet above the ground
with my foot jammed into this wedge.
Yup.
Looking up and there's another 4,000 feet to go and I've got a chalk bag.
He's got a chalk bag.
You gotta chalk bag and the sun goes down in four hours.
Good luck.
No thank you.
Not enough money in the actual world.
Yeah.
My hands sweat talking about and like I said,
I knew he was alive.
Yeah,
I knew the result and it's still freaked me out.
I think that it's one of the more interesting things about all paths in life is
like what did is,
what is it that leads someone to decide to be a surgeon?
What leads someone to decide to be,
you know,
fill in the blank,
whatever the whatever the fuck you want to do.
What leads someone decided to want to climb mountains.
This,
there's the way human beings very and the way human beings find comfort in
whatever path they choose.
Whether it's you being doing wingsuit jumping or like some people public
speaking is so terrifying for them that the idea of doing standup is just
horrific.
Like I've had friends that come to see me at the comedy store and I'll be
talking to them right before I go on stage and they're like,
do you have to prepare?
I'm like,
I'm all right.
Don't worry.
I've been doing this.
I can do it.
I do it all the time.
So I do it because I've done it so often I can just go and do it.
Whereas if they had to do it for the first,
I mean there's a thing,
a look on a person's face when you see them go on stage and the,
you know,
they'd never done it before.
Like if you go to open mic night,
you could see it,
the sheer panic and terror in their face,
but you're like,
meanwhile there's no consequences.
What is going to happen?
People are not going to like you.
They're not even going to remember you man.
Yeah.
You get off that stage,
you're fine.
He might fall to his death from a fucking giant mountain that he didn't to
climb.
Yeah.
That's real consequences.
But for him it makes for some people,
the other like the public speaking thing would be more terrifying than that.
I was going to say,
put him in that environment like,
Alex,
you're not going to climb today.
You're going to do a five minute set at the comedy store.
I think Alex would be fine doing it cause he's actually,
I think he's doing a podcast now.
Did he say he's doing a podcast?
I'm pretty sure he said he's doing a pocket.
Did you tell him he should start one?
Probably because I think you've spawned thousands of podcasts.
Well I spawned a bunch of deposits though.
Positive.
I say that like amazing to me,
the influence that you have,
it is unbelievable.
The number of people.
Like I started this because I heard Joe talk.
I'm like,
okay,
cool.
It's uncomfortable.
Like I,
I don't think about it because if I did think about it,
it freaked me out.
I mean there's,
I've said so much stupid shit.
The fact that anybody would listen to me about anything,
thousands of hours of me talking out of my ass.
Why'd you decide to start one in the first place?
Just for fun.
Just for fun and uh,
just to fuck around.
I was,
you know,
I was a little disenchanted cat had to come back to la from Colorado and I
didn't want to,
but it was just one of those things.
And when,
when I was a starting it,
it was really just a goof.
I had always wanted to do something like that because my friend Anthony
[inaudible],
he did,
he was from opie and Anthony.
He had a,
a setup in his basement and uh,
he would do this thing,
who would call it live from the compound,
from his house.
He had a green screen and he had a,
he,
he built a set in the basement.
I was like,
wow,
if he could do that,
like I didn't have the money to do anything like that at the time.
But I was like,
but if he could do that,
like maybe I could figure out how to do something like that.
So I just started off slow with webcams and shit like that and stumbled my way
through it.
I personally believe that Jerry number one should be put into a digital time
capsule and save forever.
It's one of my favorite things on you,
too.
Terrible.
It's terrible.
It's amazing how bad it gives normal people like me.
Hope.
Yes.
Yeah.
Well you do,
you get better at everything.
Yeah.
You know,
you really do.
And I've gotten,
I mean,
just in the last few years,
I've gotten so much better at listening to people and understanding where,
what they're trying to see things from their perspective and trying to ask
questions that get them to expand on their ideas better.
Yeah.
It's given me an insane education in it as far as in a bunch of ways,
not just in terms of gathering information but also in terms of how people react
to that information.
And you know,
human psychology and how human beings react to,
uh,
controversial subjects or,
you know,
how they forgive people from steaks to that's,
that's an interesting one for me.
Like this is some people that have such an,
an unwillingness to forgive people and they have no,
no empathy or compassion.
Those people were confusing to me cause I'm like,
look,
I know you fucked up.
I know somewhere it may be,
that's not sure.
Maybe he's not digitally recorded like other people's fuck ups.
So you think you're safe but you fucked up so you're being a hypocrite.
You're on.
Yeah.
Like there's,
it's when,
when someone gets busted,
you know,
it's,
it's really interesting.
And when someone like,
like there's,
there's just so much opportunity.
And one of the things that I was talking about with Jack Dorsey from,
um,
I was going to bring that up as one of the things I was talking with him about
was,
um,
how everything like literally from here forth will exist forever.
And you know,
we're going to have to figure out a way to recognize that someone from,
you know,
10 years ago when you were 15 year old kid,
you made some,
made some crazy fucking tweet.
You're not that same person now and you can't just break like that did not
happen with people with athletes recently.
They were giving him shit for stuff that they wrote in their teenagers,
but it was some,
there was some big case,
right.
Wasn't there something recently where a Heisman trophy winner,
what they're,
they're giving him a hard time for some of his past tweets.
Yeah,
I believe I was just say it,
it comes up once every other two weeks,
you know,
and they want to make it like the guy just said it yesterday.
You know,
I've already talked about it.
There's no path to redemption for those people.
That's a real problem.
And I think there should be a path to redemption for virtually everyone who's
not murdering,
raping people.
You're not stealing,
you know,
like people make mistakes.
We're all human.
We're all super flawed and um,
to,
to deny that seems like a real,
it's going to be a real problem in terms of progress in the future.
And I think that's one of the things that we were talking about earlier in terms
of,
you know,
people disagreeing with them on the left or the right and this,
we've got to figure out a way to,
to communicate with each other more civilly and to like approach people.
Like instead of approaching,
approaching someone's actions and who they are.
Like they're the enemy instead of that,
look at them with the most compassionate or forgiving view possible and look at
your,
the things that you have in common rather than the things that are inexorably
separating you.
I would like to think that most people actually do that.
I think that unfortunately extremism is winning in the country and the vocal
minority just has a much larger mega phone or microphone than the non vocal
majority.
I think most people do that,
but I don't think the people that do that waste their time posting about it or
taking up the,
you know,
just filling the narrative so it looks like there's only two positions.
That's a good point.
I would love to see some return to moderation.
Just get extremism in any shape.
I feel very uncomfortable with people who go to any length like that.
I think people are getting more and more upset at it and I think as people
recognize that it's more and more preposterous,
they're getting more and more.
There's more and more pushback and resistance.
You know what's really interesting with progressivism is that people are getting
in trouble now for things that seem like there's,
there's something like Martina Navratilova,
uh,
just got a of shit from people calling her transphobic cause she was saying that
she didn't think that biological male should be competing with biological
females and that there are people who identify as transgender who keep their
penis and compete as a man and you know,
her,
her position was like that or compete as a woman rather ship.
And her position was like that.
Listen,
that's not a,
that's not a woman.
That's a man and they have an advantage.
And she was citing all these instances and so she got all this shit from people.
So then she said,
I'm going to step back and I'm going to research this.
So she stepped back and researched it and then came back and said,
no,
I've looked at all the data but I came back harder.
She did come back harder and now they're attacking her and calling her
transphobic.
Like let's say this is not trans phobia.
This is a real thing that you're going to have to address when you're talking
about physical activities.
When someone identifies,
look,
if you want to identify as a woman or identify as a male,
I think we should all support people doing whatever they want to do as long as
it's not hurting anybody.
Totally agree.
But when you're talking about competition and you're talking about someone
identify,
I don't care if you identify as a Giraffe,
if you compete in an apple picking competition with a Giraffe,
you're going to fucking lose.
You're not a draft stupid,
right?
I mean this is just,
I mean this is an extreme version of it,
but that's nonsense.
That doesn't make any sense.
If you decide that you're a woman and you want to enter into a fucking
weightlifting competition and you weight 220 pounds and you're beating all the
other women by like fucking insane numbers,
like there was a a few world champion weightlifting winners that are women that
are actually biologically male,
so they're winning weightlifting competitions.
Just like,
what the fuck are you talking about?
Like this is great.
This is not a matter of whether or not someone should identify with something,
but it's,
you're talking about making it fair for actual biological women.
Like there's a reason why women don't compete with men is because physically
they're not as strong.
So,
and obviously there's some exceptions.
There's some weak men,
some strong women,
and there's some sort of a spectrum and you find yourself somewhere on it.
But if you're allowing biological males to compete with biological females and
just say,
oh,
he identifies as a woman led him in,
Yay,
we're all being very progressive.
And then you look at the results and you go,
wait,
he just broke all the world records.
First time in the quince.
And everyone's like,
yes,
amazing.
What a wonderful woman girl power.
Like,
that's not girl power.
You're,
you're,
you're monkeying with biology here.
This is,
this is crazy.
So what's the route?
What's the road out of that?
Like,
what does that people getting upset and it,
the time,
time being timed,
you know,
of these instances,
um,
enough of these things happen.
Enough discussion where enough of the actual reality of the facts and the data
are shoved in everyone's face enough that the new generation comes to some sort
of a rational understanding about what is and is not fair as opposed to where
people are now or they just,
no matter what,
they're scared to not push this progressive agenda and they're scared of the
blow back of Martina Navratilova who is an LBGT hero,
right?
Yes.
She's a fucking hero.
She was a lesbian woman who was a world champion tennis player and now they're
the left are attacking her,
so they're,
they're eating their own in a spectacular fashion where you have these trans
people who don't want to look at reality and then people that support the trans
people because they don't want to be considered in any way,
shape or form anything other than the most progressive of progressive and it's
nonsense.
It's like,
okay,
I think you're right though in the generational fix to it.
I think that's true of a lot of the stuff that like one of the,
I get asked all the time,
school shootings,
right?
It's like the topic of the day.
Yeah.
I don't have a solution for it,
but I know it's not going to be overnight.
It'll be generational in nature,
just like it crept in generational in nature.
I think a lot of these problems people look for a light switch solution where
the solution in and of itself is the exact opposite of that.
Yeah,
I think you're right.
Um,
I don't see any solution to that either.
And I think there's a lot of positions that people feel like they're supposed to
take.
And if you're on the left,
the big position that you're supposed to take his gun control,
get rid of the guns,
the guns or the problem.
Look at all these people shooting people with guns,
guns,
guns and all the mass shootings.
What they have in common guns.
They all have guns in common and they want to take away guns.
And then there's the people on the right and the lucky you're not going to,
I've never done anything wrong with my gun.
You're not taking my fucking gone.
And then there's this fucking in stock,
unstoppable battle between these two sides.
And that there's a lot of factors like what,
what happens to a human that leads them to get to this state of mind where
they're able to go into a school and shoot it up.
Like what is that?
What,
what,
what?
What could possibly be going on?
How do we stop that from ever taking place?
The,
the,
these people have to be in some sort of insane pain.
There has to be something unbelievably wrong with their life that they're
capable of doing this.
How do we stop that?
How do we look at that?
It's like it's,
this is our,
our global community.
If this is our national community,
how do we stop this from happening in our national community?
I don't know what the answer to that is.
I think there's an
answer to stopping school shootings and not to over simplify anything.
There's,
I would say there's a couple key issues.
One of them is location.
The other one is motivation.
You can solve the location issue.
Like if we as a country,
we're legitimately interested in stopping school shootings.
How many have ever occurred at a school where the president has children go
zero.
Why?
Because it's defended,
right?
They actually take a proactive approach to it.
They're going to have layers of security defense in depth.
They're probably going to have somebody looking out the front door or a system
looking out the front door controlled actually points,
uh,
entry and exit points.
You're gonna have a metal detector.
You're going to have security staff onsite,
right?
So you can control the location aspect.
And I,
you know,
I go to a,
every time I met my kids' school or,
and unfortunately or fortunately every building I've ever been,
and I'm viewing it from a pseudo tactical perspective at least.
So I'll go walk around my kids' school and there's issues that I see from a
perspective of somebody who would want to exploit that from aggressors
perspective,
but they could all be solved.
But that doesn't solve the second aspect of that,
the motivation,
because I have absolutely no answer as to why a 17 year old kid with think that
a solution of any kind would be to kill their classmates.
I don't understand that.
At all and all the LP.
It's funny like at every shooting,
surprisingly enough,
there's two things,
a gun and the shooter and vast majority of the time I hear people talking about
the gun.
Yeah.
I think we've got to balance that conversation and talk about the motivation.
Yeah,
100% and also psych medications.
You know,
you got to talk about that.
The,
the rise in psych medications,
Scott,
to be correlated with the rise of school shootings.
I mean the,
the amount of people that are on psych medication,
and I understand that correlation does not equal causation.
It's not necessarily that the medication's forcing them to do this,
but there's,
I don't know what study has been done on what is,
what is the effect and is there some sort of a connection other than the fact
that they're all on medication.
Is there some sort of a connection between taking certain types of psych
medication with certain biological makeup that allows you to have this diffusion
of reality like this,
this,
this is some some weird thing happens to them.
Where a capable of horrific things and horrific actions,
like how much of that is monkeying with the human neuro chemistry?
I don't know.
That's why I think the location portion,
it's not that it's an easy solution but it's,
it is solvable but isn't the problem funding like there's no money for to pay
for teachers.
They don't have money to like secure schools.
It depends on how serious we want to take it.
If,
if we really wanted to stop it.
What I'm saying is there are ways that can stop it.
I'm not saying those ways are easy.
I'm not saying that those ways are cheap,
but there are concrete things just looking at a structure from being vulnerable
to an assault.
There are things that could be done,
but that doesn't solve the school shooting problem.
Right.
It changes the address because the individual that would want to go do that at a
school.
If you make a target hard that doesn't remove the motivation.
And so I'm saying there's location motivation and obviously a lot of other
factors.
The location one,
if you saw that you still got to talk about the shooter.
Right.
And I mean,
that's where I bumped my head up.
Again,
I don't,
I would actually like to see this country have a conversation instead of
entrenched positions,
either the left or the right.
Uh,
all guns should be bands.
Come get them with your coat,
my cold,
dead hands.
Right.
Uh,
which I don't,
uh,
again,
I find myself in the middle of that.
I don't agree with either of those positions because it's more nuance than just
the gun and the shooter is the combination of all those things.
But I don't even feel like we're having a conversation in this country.
I feel like a lot of people are talking.
I don't think anybody is listening.
And I,
you know,
I go to the schools in the neighborhood where,
where my kids go to school.
I don't see a single change that they have made.
Yeah,
I think you're 100% correct.
And that there doesn't seem to be any real,
there's no real plans to stop this stuff.
And I don't think anybody has a real answer.
And that's one of the reasons why it's so confusing to people because you could
dwell on it and roll it over in your head all day long.
And there's nothing that stands out as obvious.
Like,
Hey,
there's a fire.
Go pour water on it.
It's obvious there's no,
there's no solution.
And the low hanging fruit is the metaphor for this school shootings would be,
there's a gun,
go pour water on that.
Right,
right,
right.
But the more nuanced and complex problem is actually the human being behind it.
And I see people,
they just,
well that's too difficult.
So I'm gonna throw my hands up and give up.
Yeah.
I mean,
but also too,
I think it's important to point out that actually it's a,
thankfully it's incredibly rare that it actually happens.
And it's funny because you look at the stats and you start digging into where
the stats come from and two groups of people,
and I'm sure you see this across a variety of topics,
we'll take the same study and derived two different sets of numbers.
There's school shootings and then there's shootings that happen at schools and
you can make one number look bigger and one number looks smaller.
Like if you wanted to include the number of people who commit suicide in a
school parking lot,
which at a national level is considered a school shooting because it occurred at
a school,
you can inflate and conflate the number of times and the frequency with which it
happens.
If you strip that information out,
it gives you a much more accurate perspective of how often it's happening.
Same thing and when you remove suicides from gun violence and the total number
of deaths,
so,
but again,
that takes a refined,
a nuanced person that's willing to actually look at it as opposed to just
repeating what their bumper sticker says.
Yeah,
I saw that when Ted Nugent debated Pierce Morgan on television and was talking
to him about gun violence and the actual numbers,
and he was saying,
well,
this is,
these are the real statistics and this is why the numbers are so high.
How many of these,
when you're including gun violence,
how many of these people are like,
criminals are being shot in the act by police officers?
How many of them are people defending their home from a break in?
How many of them are suicides?
How man,
once you get through that,
you get to the end of it.
Then you get to gang violence.
How many,
how many of them are,
uh,
responsible?
How many deaths are attributed to gang violence?
How many deaths are attributed to,
uh,
you know,
I mean there's,
there's,
there's a lot of different factors.
Then you get to these mass shootings.
Yup.
So the,
the mass shootings,
it's,
it,
it's a relatively small percentage,
but that doesn't give anybody any comfort for anybody that's suffered.
Of
course.
Yeah,
it does.
And it,
again,
it's,
it doesn't excuse it.
It's just,
thankfully it happens infrequently.
I wish the number was zero.
We're not better.
And I think the answer to getting it to zero will be generational because it
grew generationally.
Yeah,
I think it will go away generationally.
But how does it go to w w what?
What fundamental changes have to happen in the way human beings exist?
That we stop any,
anything that right now we're to all the difference.
I mean,
it would be a terrible world if we said,
hey,
we're just going to have to accept that people are never going to evolve
socially,
emotionally,
whatever it is.
It's causing people to lash out the way they do what,
I mean,
what a horrible world it would be if we say no,
that people are just going to be like this forever.
We're not just flawed but flawed and ruthless and cruel and violent and awful.
And that's just the way people are forever.
I mean,
I think there's improvements you can make on both sides.
Right?
So there's a,
there's a gun and there was a shooter.
There are,
I couldn't be a more VM and supporter of the Second Amendment,
like I completely and utterly support it.
Uh,
but I'm anti irresponsibility.
Yeah.
And there's a lot of things that we could do as a nation that would improve
safety via responsibility.
I mean,
look at this,
the stats on the percentage of American gun owners that don't own a safe,
it's over 50% yeah.
Which is speaks to access.
And what sucks about any improvements that we make.
I,
you'll never know about it because you're never going to know about the school
shooting that you stopped.
Really.
You know what I mean?
It because he doesn't make the news.
But that doesn't mean I'm,
I,
my default position is we can do better.
There's ways that we could,
I think that the reasonable gun legislation that already exists,
there's ways that we could improve communication.
Inner Agency,
like the Aurora shooter as a perfect example,
it took a pistol in,
killed five people the day he got fired,
an injured five police officers.
He shouldn't have had the gun.
He was a convicted felon.
His felony did not show up when they had the a background check for his job.
But it did show up for the background check,
I believe for his concealed weapons permit.
But oftentimes I see it where there's this disconnect between agencies not
sharing information very much like the military civilian military infrastructure
prior to nine 11 agency didn't want to talk to the FBI and the NSA because
budget and relevancy and this is mine and that's yours and this is my rice boy.
Get the fuck away from me.
I don't want to share information.
I think we could do better on the regulations that are in place.
I'm not saying add any more,
but maybe let's figure out a way where we could share information or at least
make sure we're living up to the letter of the intent and the letter of the law
on that side of the house.
And then on the other side of the house,
I,
you had a pin tweet for a long time and I'm going to totally murder this,
uh,
when it comes to exactly what it was,
but some of the longest we're not,
we don't have a gun prices.
We have a mental health crisis.
We have a mental health crisis disguised as a gun crisis or a mental health
problem decides the gun problem
and just like we can do better on the firearm side of the,
we can do better on the mental health side of the house.
And I just see people throwing their hands up and attacking the low hanging
fruit because I think the mental health side of the house is a more difficult
issue than the firearm.
I think it's the most difficult issue,
you know,
and I think,
uh,
everyone that I know,
including myself,
has had bad moments in their life and has struggled.
And the the struggle,
especially mental health struggle,
struggle with depression or being unhappy or anger or any of the things that
keep you off of a healthy baseline.
Those,
those,
those moments in life are,
they vary wildly in how people experience them,
what to what level people experience them,
what impact they have on them and whether or not there can recover from these
things.
And for some people they feel like there is no recovery and the only way out is
to just go out with a bang.
Like literally.
And this is a lot of what you're seeing in these school shootings as suicide by
cop.
Yeah,
I mean this,
this is one of the things that people want.
They want to go out in a blaze of glory and what,
what the fuck is going on,
where we let people get to that point without stepping in and trying to help.
And do they have anybody that even notices,
do they have anyone around them that knows that,
that this fucked up in this far gone?
You know,
I mean,
we all like to think that that could never happen to us.
That we could never get to a point where we're so despondent and filled with
anger and hate and fear and,
and self loathing that we want to do something horrific.
But every person who does something horrific is a human being.
Right.
And the difference between you and them might be genetic,
it might be environmental,
it might be life experience,
but they are human being just like you and I and something horrifically went
wrong in their life to the point where they are in this position where they show
up at that,
that school shooting in Illinois just a couple of days ago.
Some guy got fired.
Yup.
Went back to work and just shot everybody up.
Like what the fuck?
That guy worked there for 15 years.
Like what is it that it that gets when someone gets to a point where this is,
this is what flashes in their mind as a solution.
Go back with a gun,
make everybody pay.
I've felt it myself that feeling,
um,
overseas when it loose close friends,
that first absolute feeling you have is an as a,
an anger that I don't have the vocabulary to describe an all you want to do is
burn the world to the ground.
But it was fleeting and I didn't do it.
And I just don't know how we provide the barrier for people if they can.
And when it comes to mental health,
I mean somebody with more horsepower between the ears than me knit in the is
going to need to solve that problem because I don't understand it.
But I do understand that feeling.
But what I needed was time and I don't know how to provide that.
Well,
you also had character
stir and discipline and a lot of things that many people lack in your to
mitigate these horrific feelings and this severe depression and anger.
Some people don't have those mental health tools.
They don't have those tools.
I mean,
you already a seal,
right?
You're already a guy who has endured more than most human beings will ever in
terms of physically and emotionally and how to get through that hump to become
one of the elite operators in this country.
That just having that as a baseline,
like having that as a you,
you,
you have the toolset to endure more than most.
Some people are just not capable of handling any real adversity.
Anything bad that comes down the pipe for them,
they just fall apart.
And I think for many people there's a real extreme feeling of a lack of purpose
in life.
There's an extreme feeling of a lack of a lack of meaning that that nothing they
do matters.
That they don't matter,
that no one cares about them,
whether they're or they're gone.
People either mock them or disregard them all together and they,
they want people to know who they are.
And that's one of the reasons why they do these things.
I can see that for sure.
But again,
if I'm being objectively honest about myself,
I did have those tools and
probably the only thing that prevented me from acting out in that moment is that
I didn't have access to the individuals that I wanted to act out against.
Okay.
And I mean it's like I said,
I understand it.
I don't have a solution for it at all,
but I understand it.
Yeah.
Well you would be able to understand it more than most in coming from that place
of having lost friends and being in that intense and also being in this
environment where people are shooting and killing people on a regular basis and
you're directly part of that and directly connected to it,
it makes violence so much more tangible.
Well,
I mean,
at the same time,
I don't want to pay it now a horrible picture.
Uh,
there is a ton of misconceptions about what I used to do.
Right?
And it comes from books and movies and TV shows because in 60 minutes all that
happens is bullets whizzing by your head and shit blowing up.
The reality is you're not exposed to violence that often overseas you are over a
long term I guess in the aggregate,
but it's not as bad as people.
It's not as bad as people I think often would maybe want to romanticize it as
being bad because then they can maybe excuse away behaviors that come from that.
Does that bother you about movies when you see movies about you should,
if,
if my wife was here,
all you'd have to say is,
do you enjoy watching a war movie with your husband?
She said,
oh my God,
she just get out of the room,
get out of the room cause I can't do it.
But it's,
it's,
it drives me nuts but it also sets bad expectations.
I mean I had some of the best times in my life overseas as well and it wasn't
all about loss and it certainly wasn't all about loss of life.
There'd be whirlwind periods of time where that happened and there'd be other
periods of time where you were just training people,
you know,
or we're going out and actually meeting leaders in the city and having meals
with them.
And then yeah,
that night you might chuck get your stuff on and go bang and for a night,
but the same time,
it's a,
a mix of all of those things.
It's,
I'm grateful for the experiences that I have from a military service.
Probably the best day of my life was the day I got shot.
It changed my perspective of who I thought about who I thought I was.
It forced me to lift my head up and think about the future more than just the
job that I had because my ability to do my job is thrown into my face.
I thought I was one.
Once I realized I wasn't gonna die,
I was like,
oh my God,
I'm not going to be able to do the job I've always wanted to do for the rest of
my life.
So I started thinking about the future again.
I wouldn't,
I would not be sitting here talking you today if I hadn't had been shot.
And when it happened in that moment,
it was the worst day of my life.
And I look back on it,
it probably was the most,
maybe wasn't the best day of my life,
but perhaps one of the most meaningful changes in direction for me as a human
being.
So there is positive that comes out of that negative.
It's not all bad.
It's,
I think I got more positive,
more good than bad from 15 years at war.
That's,
it's interesting that that does happen,
right?
That's some bad moment in your life.
Could lead to a greater life overall.
Yeah.
Complete shift in perspective.
I had never thought about anything in my life except unsatiable desire to be a
seal.
And then I became a seal.
I'm like,
this is awesome because it's pre nine 11.
So we just,
uh,
worked out,
drank and then worked out and drank.
And then nine 11 happened and I,
my,
my world went from conceptual to practical and it was way different than I
thought it was going to be because I've watched the same movies.
Um,
and then you get over it and you're like,
oh well this is,
this is substantially,
substantially different.
And
it built and it was a lot of the things that I thought it wasn't going to be a,
and even more than I thought it possibly could be in some of those directions.
But I don't know it
people I think often paint,
uh,
war or the experiences associated with Warrah solely negative.
And I also just like when it comes to the conversations and being on the stream
extremes,
I would love to pull that more back into the middle and actually have a
conversation about it.
I think amazing changes can come from people in those environments.
What is it about war movies that drive you the most crazy?
The fact that almost everything in them is an accurate,
almost everything.
Biggest thing that drives me fucking crazy is when grenades,
creative fireball
really well.
Yeah.
Cause it happens in like every movie they throw a grenade and a 55 gallon drum
of gasoline explodes and people go flying backwards and cars flip over.
If you throw a grenade,
it goes pop and it puts some dust up in the air and if you're waiting for the
fireball,
you're going to be there for the rest of your natural life.
It's just not going and they're not that effective.
They're fun.
Don't get me wrong,
but they're not that effective.
I did not know that.
They don't create a fireball.
No,
I've never seen a grenade go off.
Obviously.
I'm sure Jamie can pull one up.
It just goes.
It's dust is all of this.
I've seen one in a video of that.
I'm sure for a moment like the momentary explosion there was a flash,
but other than that it's literally just dust flying up in the air.
What?
What is the best military movie that's the most accurate or the most the least
offensive navy seals starring Charlie Sheen.
Really?
No,
not at all.
Oh Jesus Christ.
I'm wanting to fell down
that fucking guy.
Probably of more people in to come into the seal teams than anybody else.
Really?
Oh my God.
Yeah.
I mean these fallen through skylights with MP fives and handlebar mustaches.
You know,
there's snipers calling himself.
God,
I can't see anything.
I'm switching to starlight blasting people through a concrete wall.
They're doing free fall jumps are in submarines.
Like that's an entire 30 year career to do all that shit and 60 minutes they,
you take that expectation,
you come to the teams like God,
I'm kind of bored right now.
So was that the war area is
bang,
Bang,
Bang.
Okay,
I'm going to run boys.
Yup.
I want to make it.
And he's got the,
the,
the requisite.
A scarf around the neck and first off,
one of those.
So what kind of asshole wears a red scarf and an environment where there's no
red.
He's got green utility is on from Vietnam.
You want to read them all?
Yeah.
This is so hilarious.
So another one is,
especially with,
you know Charlie now,
like such a fucking psychotic partier.
And so apparently,
apparently so they came to the buds compound and did a little bit of training
with the guys and I guess there was some bathroom breaks and they'd just be
like,
all right,
you guys ready for some more PT?
Oh really?
That makes sense.
I've always see hearing that 18th hand,
but I want to believe it's true.
Well,
you know who I hear trains diligently and really hard,
uh,
and like takes it super seriously and it's like one of the most humble guys
you'll ever meet.
He's Keanu Reeves.
That doesn't surprise me.
Yeah.
It doesn't surprise me either,
but I heard some people that have,
uh,
had interacted with him when he was training for,
um,
John Wiki.
Yeah.
Including my Jujitsu instructor,
John Jacques Machado and my friend.
He can Machado's John Jack's brother and a bunch of other,
uh,
he,
he worked out with a bunch of their Machado's.
In fact,
I think Carlos as well.
Uh,
but you know,
he really wanted to learn actual Jujitsu.
So he shoot rain with them.
Yeah,
he did real tactical courses.
And so his,
uh,
his tactical proficiency shows in that movie.
And so to get back to stuff that bothers me,
it's the 72 round pistol magazine.
Yeah.
Cause I'm counting,
I'm like,
that's 15.
Oh 25 30.
Ah,
or the shotgun that has 48 rounds it so that I can't do it.
I'm like throwing stuff at the TV and my wife just points.
She says get out like I can't do
I think so.
Sicario I love Sicario.
There's a scene at the border that has one of the most blatant,
uh,
just errors in movie.
There's a guy
pointing a gun,
he's supposedly a CIA and he's pointing the gun out the windshield and you can
see that the bolt to the rifle is locked to the rear.
Oh No.
Which means the armor on set handed it to him,
you know,
clear and safe.
And he just went and they filmed it and nobody caught it.
And I saw that movie.
I'm like,
turn that shit off.
I can't watch any.
Of course.
Yeah.
It ruins it for me now.
Why don't they fix stuff like that?
You would think that you're making a movie about military or about guns?
Like,
yeah,
TP gun nuts are going to notice that they,
but they probably didn't catch it in the editing process.
It's so fast.
It's probably up there for three seconds.
But if you know,
I mean I,
you look at a gun and like you just,
if it was your primary tool for years,
you're going to,
you're looking for certain things all the time.
Yes.
Here we go.
Yeah.
I look for someone who doesn't know though.
It looks super serious.
Well that's why they're still watching the movie and I left,
Huh?
Yup.
Bolt to the rear.
Ah,
so it does to the rear.
Yup.
Go ahead and pull the trigger there.
Go ahead son.
This shit.
Ah,
obviously an empty magazine.
Yeah.
Hey silly.
So nobody caught that in the editing process is what it is.
Clean not see that.
No.
Don't you think they digitally could have moved that forward?
They 100% couldn't move cause he didn't fire in that scene anyway.
Yeah,
just pushed that pitch up.
Just Photoshop that sucker.
I it makes sense.
Came in way less significant thing.
I get crazy when I watch people play pool and movies that obviously can't play.
Oh,
I can drive me nuts.
Drives me nuts.
Like if I see someone like it's supposed to be some pool hustler and I see so
they have a bullshit bridge and they're,
they're gripping the like you can see things in movies like uh,
my friends who smoked cigarettes say they can tell when someone doesn't smoke.
Oh for sure.
Yeah,
because when you smoke there's just so like a casual relaxed way that you're
holding the cigarette and the way you're drawing up.
But when someone's like never smoked before and they've got this weird thing to
do and like,
oh that guy doesn't really smoke.
I'm like,
how the fuck can you tell it?
Because I smoke.
It's like,
another thing that bugs me is you watch any tactical scene where they're like
moving down a hallway and it's like,
why is your gun pointed at your buddies face?
Like why are you aiming as drag?
And then the way that they make entry into rooms,
it's like,
awesome.
I like to play Russian roulette with my life as well.
Like,
it just drives me.
Absolutely.
What about zero dark 30?
That movie fucking sucks.
What sucks about it?
You know what drove me crazy that that last time?
Do we have the redhead lady?
What is yelling at all of those trained killers?
I was like,
I don't think they listen to her.
There are some creative liberties that are taken in that movie from soup to
nuts.
I mean like was that person,
the lady who yelled at those guys are the one,
the woman who was in charge of,
was that a real human in real life?
It was based off of a real human for sure.
Like a
lot of the things in that movie were based on real events.
However,
if you're trying to get tickets to get people's seats in our,
their butts and seats,
you got to glamorize stuff.
So a lot of people,
because in that movie,
you know the,
um,
the source drives up in the vehicle and detonates himself.
That actually happened,
that killed a bunch of people in calced.
Um,
if as long as you look at it as entertainment,
that movies,
okay.
If you look at it with a refined,
I like,
are they doing this correctly?
No.
They're all going to die.
Yeah.
I mean it's,
uh,
it just,
we would need another four hours to literally go down the list of things,
but it's just things are compressed.
Things that would never happen,
happen for the sake of creating a,
an,
an an intoxicating or did,
uh,
emotional scene on camera and it's tough to watch because I'm sitting here,
I'm like,
get out of the door,
get out the door.
I'm getting anxiety watching these damn movies because you don't hang out in
front of open doors unless you want to get shot.
Now,
how many different things were fucked up about that movie?
Uh,
Joe,
only the things that we're after the opening scene.
It's a long movie.
It's a disaster.
Yeah.
It's just,
I don't want to talk about it.
It dominates like myself.
I'm like,
that's a good fucking movie.
Seems pretty realistic.
Well,
think about it from entertainment.
It's a great entertaining movie.
It asks the same question about the movie American sniper or lone survivor.
They're all based around certain things that have been enhanced to make it more
entertaining.
Yes.
And,
and I get it.
They're there to make money.
They're not there to tell historically accurate.
Do you know Marcus?
I do not know Marcus well,
but I do know Marcus [inaudible].
I know.
Um,
I don't know how he felt.
I don't know if you'd ever say he was making a movie.
Yeah.
But I mean,
I'm sure they only listened to him so much,
you know?
Yeah.
Uh,
given how I can,
again,
having not been there and I can only imagine how horrific that incident must be
for him to deal with on a daily level.
I would bet he wasn't very involved.
I would almost rather them,
if that was me,
I think I would almost rather say,
you know what,
just make the movie that you want to make because I don't want to sit here and
explain exactly what happened and recreate these scenes and talk about how this
person died over here.
Like I just go,
you know,
go to town.
Is there any movie that you've ever seen about war where you go,
that makes sense.
First 10 minutes of Saving Private Ryan is unbelievable.
Not for accuracy,
for capturing the essence of what it feels like and the switch between utter
fear to excitement,
to joy,
to anger in the matter of a second,
another movie that does a good aspect or a good job of capturing,
capturing some of those aspects I would say is also Black Hawk down,
not for accuracy,
but to capture the chaos that have,
how a plan can come unraveled and how just how chaotic can be an handshouse.
Sometimes you can feel so helpless but you're only solution is to drive into the
problem instead of moving away from it.
So those,
those capture the essence of it.
Well,
from a technical perspective,
I honestly cannot think of a single movie that does a justice.
Wow.
It would have to be like a 50 hour movie though because of course,
I mean Black Hawk down,
I think it was a multiple day incident in that movie is 90 minutes.
Right.
So they get rid of all the boring bs stuff.
That is actually what you do.
The vast majority of your job.
If I look at my career,
probably greater than 95% of my career I spent training and then 5% is spent in
combat.
Really?
Yup.
And that is that.
That's average.
I would say there are people who are maybe a little bit higher and people who
are a little bit lower,
but you're not going to spend more than at most maybe 10% of your career in
combat.
Even if your job is directly tied to combat cause you gotta to train,
you get a plan.
The missions,
I mean our,
our normal planning cycle was 24 to 72 hours sitting in front of PowerPoint
considering whether or not I should hang myself or blow my brains out because
we're arguing over the font that we're using to submit permission approval,
grilling.
Oh,
you're studying the,
whether you're studying the terrain.
I've had slides and mission briefs sent back,
not be approved because I didn't orient the helicopter,
the correct direction on the slide.
They're like,
hey,
you need to fix this and then resubmit it.
Like if you want it to shut down the average day military,
it wouldn't be through a kinetic act.
You would need to put some type of code into Microsoft office and we're done
because we operate on Microsoft PowerPoint,
Microsoft Word and Microsoft office.
We'd sit there and we'd plan and we would brief and we'd submit for approval.
That's three days.
Then you'd go do an objective that would last for 10 hours.
Repeat,
repeat the cycle.
I'm too add for that.
It's,
well,
you break up the tasks so each like is it the last thing you'd want is one
person creating the entire plan,
so somebody who's doing the communication plan in the medivac plan,
the insertion plan,
the route planning you.
We don't ever really brief what we're going to do inside of the objective
because that's kind of the soup and nuts that you train for at all times.
Like that's everything has to get there and then,
okay,
that's actually our job,
but we focus on all those other things.
Then primary,
secondary,
tertiary plan for each one of those things.
Phase lines for each one of those things.
None of that has ever shown up in any movie.
Uh,
what doesn't show up in any movies is vast majority of time the intelligence is
bad and you hit what's called a dry hole.
You go to a building,
you approached the structure,
you breached the door and it's just the intelligence is wrong.
It's either empty or it's the wrong person.
That happens all the time.
That doesn't,
it's not exciting though.
So we pay the people money,
they fix their door and we go back and we try to find the person again,
none of that shows up in any of the mediums cause it's too,
they're too compressed with you all your experience in the military and your,
your knowledge of what the real world
in these combat environments is like.
What do you,
how do you feel when you hear people talk about defunding the military or
decreasing the military or that we don't need it or that we shouldn't have the
kind of budget that we have right now,
the people that don't understand the real threats that are out there and that if
you do not have a well trained,
well funded,
experienced military that really understands these things,
you've got real danger at your door.
Yup.
Uh,
I'm glad that they live in a place where they have enough space to develop those
thoughts because they're not under pressure because the military is doing the
job that they should be doing.
There are,
like I said,
so many misconceptions about what the military does.
Uh,
what we do overseas,
how many countries we are in overseas,
how deep we are into some of these countries,
how forecasted and how forward looking the military is looking for emerging
threats as opposed to just responding and all of that creates space so people
can exercise their right to voice their first amendment.
You know,
right.
Of saying those things.
I don't.
Does it frustrate you though,
that they don't have a real understanding?
I'm grateful that they live in a place where they don't have that great
understanding because like I said,
they have the space to be confused.
They're not pushed under a thumb.
They're not being told you have to say this or it's going to be your fucking
head in the square.
Right?
Yeah.
It is frustrating for me at times,
but I balance that with that's,
that's what this country is supposed to be about.
You're supposed to be able to voice your descent.
Right,
and I,
and I believe that the system will correct in is it does correct for itself.
There are people that believe that,
but I think the most,
the majority of people,
again,
silent majority versus extreme minority,
I think those people are in the extreme minority,
but they're very vocal.
I think most people are incredibly appreciative of what the military does.
But having said that,
if you've never served in the military and you've never been in a combat
occupation,
and then you've never applied that occupation for real,
there's going to be a gap.
And there's going to be a gap in understanding and that's okay.
So it's frustrating.
Yes,
but I'm,
I'm glad that it exists and I'm glad that they are not in this country,
is not in a position where they are getting drafted and forced into that
position.
I'm glad that it was me that did that and had to bear any weight or burden that
came with that to allow them to have whatever opinion they want.
That's a great perspective.
That's a very healthy way of looking at it.
Um,
and I probably think it's probably the only manageable way of looking at it.
I think you'd go crazy otherwise because of the way,
and then you,
what are you going to do?
Go to a rally and hold up another light.
It's like what's right.
I mean,
I,
because it initially I have to fight back the initial anger,
but eventually it give me a little bit of time and the,
you know,
hopefully relatively sane head is going to prevail.
And I had,
you know,
again that night I got hurt.
It changed the way that I thought about things.
If I had never gotten hurt and uh,
and the,
and I had never thought about my own mortality and I had never thought about,
I spend a lot of time thinking about whether or not what I did in the military
has it had any impact 0.0001 I don't know if I would have thought about that if
all I had ever done was just doing the occupation that I did.
I needed that lifting of my head to have that perspective.
I did.
I don't think all people do,
but I needed that.
How long do I keep going?
I was going to say,
I think that night in a,
in some ways helps me have the perspective I have now with those people.
How,
how long is the average career of someone who's a seal?
Well,
if you want to retire,
you got to do 20 years in a wake up and they should change.
It's a wake up,
wake up the next day.
You got to 20 years,
you have to do 20 years to the day.
So wake up the day after your 20th.
Uh,
but they need to change the term.
Also retirement pay in the military should be,
in my opinion,
at least replaced with money that you are going to get paid until you find your
second career because you're not going to retire on $3,000 a month,
you know?
Uh,
but if you,
if you want to make it to retirement,
you have to do 20 years.
The only reason I get a retirement is because I was medically retired.
So they basically,
I don't know how it happens in the system,
but they put me in that category is essentially the made at 20 years.
What,
what happens with most guys when they hit 20 years,
do they retire?
It's hit or miss.
Um,
on the enlisted side of the house,
they start throwing what at that phase of your life is going to be a lot of
money at you.
They'll try to get you to reenlist.
And I never took this money and so I'm not exactly sure,
but it's about five years of reenlistment and it's about 150 grand,
which is a ton of money if you're in the military.
And if you realist a while,
you're overseas,
every penny of that is tax free because you're going to get it in increments per
150 per year total for the five years.
It's not,
here's the deal,
it's a lot of money.
If you're used to having your head down and you used to make in 90 a year and
you're in your late thirties and you realize,
you know,
oh my God,
I could buy a house with that money,
right?
You'll take it.
And He,
and uh,
and every year that you do over 20,
they will add,
I believe,
one half of a percentage point to your military retirement.
So if you do 20 years in the military,
you will get 50% of your base pay,
which doesn't include the dive pay,
dental pay,
jump pay,
hazardous duty pay,
all the difference in money that I made,
I get the exact same retirement,
which is totally fine.
And I signed up for this as a person who was in front of a radar scope for 20
years.
We get the exact same paycheck at the end.
Uh,
if you do 21 years,
you get 50 and a half,
22 years,
51% so it keeps incrementally going up.
So some guys will go up to 30 most guys by the time they get to 20 and I will
say this,
it depends on what's going on in the world.
When it was peak war time,
2007,
2009 not a lot of guys were getting out.
Most of the guys were reopened cause they wanted to strap the boots back on and
go back overseas and they're like,
hey,
I'll re enlist while I'm overseas tax free money.
I get to go do what I want to do.
It's a,
it's a win win.
But most people as the operational tempo has slowed.
Anecdotally what I've seen is they are looking more towards a future kind of get
out around 20 if not,
they'll get out around 25 after they take that reenlistment bonus.
And if you're staying in to like your thirties you're in for the long haul.
When you look at the news,
do you pay attention to potential conflicts internationally and the things that
are going on?
Yes and no.
I not from a,
I'm not looking at them to inform my opinion.
I'm just kinda curious as to what the news agencies are reporting because having
lived on the other side of that and doing things that will eventually make the
news days,
weeks or months later,
the news is generally behind on that cycle and the military does do a good job
and has continued to do a better job of kind of forecasting those things and
spreading out as much as necessary.
But do you see anything now like you know,
I know Trump got a lot of criticism for saying that we're going to pull troops
out of Syria and when,
when you see the debate about that or actions possible actions against North
Korea and all this kind of stuff,
like how do you,
do you,
do you view this,
I mean obviously you view this as a guy who has served,
it's been overseas,
but do you,
do you look at things like these are potential issues that are coming up and
things you need to be concerned with?
The Syria and Syria one,
there are guys from the community over there.
They've been actively engaged.
Iraq,
it's funny,
the news reported for a long time.
We've withdrawn from Iraq,
all US troops out of Iraq.
No they weren't.
We've always had a presence there since we invaded in 2003 so,
and I can go
tit for tat on a lot of issues where the news gets it wrong,
which is why I don't necessarily look at it for me and to inform my opinion.
Uh,
Syria.
Certainly any area where
we allow a place for the,
and the only word I have for it is evil to grow.
It's going to happen.
The problem with the strategy that I see it is,
is that actually,
so we started in Afghanistan,
and again,
this is my opinion,
not the military opinion.
I can only speak for myself.
We went into Afghanistan,
we were incredibly effective.
So we cut the head off of that snake,
but it spawned two more.
Uh,
you go into Iraq,
you can argue whether or not we were effective,
but then all of a sudden we started seeing foreign fighters coming in from all
of these different countries and the tactics that we started seeing used in
Iraq,
like my first deployment to Afghanistan in 2003 now 2002,
uh,
it was not uncommon to drive around in vehicles that were not ballistic.
They were not a resistant to mines.
It would just,
it Tacoma,
a thin skin to come over.
The bolt would zip right through.
Fast forward to Afghanistan in 2008 and they're starting to see vehicles being
detonated by bombs that we first saw in Iraq that were coming across the border
into Syria where they were had the ability to allow,
again,
for lack of a better term,
that evil to grow,
to learn to come across the border,
to engage American forces,
then to flee into a sovereign nation.
We couldn't do anything about.
Then we started seeing that in Afghanistan,
but we've got effective anytime that these people would get together and have a
large group,
we'd get effective at either capturing them or killing them so they realize they
need to be disaggregated.
So now we've spread this.
I think the last stat that I saw as isis is in 64 countries and the problem that
I see with the u s military is that we're very,
very good at going in and cutting the head off the snake,
but we're not good at creating and holding infrastructure and the timeline
required to hold that infrastructure as well beyond the Palette.
I think of most Americans,
and the best example I can point to is South Korea.
We still have basis with an American presence in South Korea.
That war ended decades ago.
We still have basis in Germany.
We have bases in Italy now.
We're not necessarily using it for the same purposes,
but if we really want to control that area,
we have to be prepared to stay there for that long.
And I don't think the u s military one has enough personnel to do that and I
don't think the American populace has the Palette to allow that to happen.
Do you think that that's necessary the,
in order to protect people from,
whether,
whether it's isis or whatever comes after isis?
I mean,
yeah,
obviously isis is fairly recent,
right?
You went through al Qaeda,
Isis and they change.
Yeah,
the Isol and all that,
whatever could be next.
Yeah.
So you,
you feel like we have to maintain presence in that part of the world,
period.
I think we should use the military as a measure of last resort.
I think that war should be a measure of absolutely last resort.
And I would love to see us evolve to a point where we use it less and less and
less.
Um,
I describe it as you're standing at a dam and you can see a little spout coming
out.
Do you put your finger in the spout knowing that it's not going to fix the
problem,
but it was going to buy you time to hopefully have somebody come and fix the
damn right.
That's the option I would go for versus just leaving it as it is and allowing it
to continue to weaken the dam.
Or another sprout would come out my theory that the military is really well
served to provide that space,
to put that finger in that sprout.
So yes,
I think if we find an area where these ideologies are thriving,
we have to do what is necessary to remove that ideology and hopefully destroy
it.
Not,
not resettle it somewhere else,
but actually destroyed.
So yes,
the short answer is absolutely.
If we find areas where can squash this down,
we have to go.
But I just hope that there's people smarter than me that had a much longer term
strategy because all we're doing,
in my opinion,
is the finger in the dam.
And is there a longer term strategy,
like when you see all the global conflicts?
I mean,
is there a time that we get,
I mean it's,
it's,
it sounds insane to say that there's never going to be a time where there's no
war.
It sounds like an insane thing to say.
I don't know if there's ever been a time,
at least globally,
not that the u s was involved,
but I don't know if there's ever been a time where there hasn't been worth,
I don't think their house,
I don't think there can be because,
and I effect,
we talked about this the first day I met you,
there's x people and there's white people.
They're not going to get along.
It doesn't matter what your belief is.
You have an access somewhere that has another belief.
And if you go to the extreme end of that belief,
that individual may be willing to take action against you,
violent action against you for your belief.
And there's,
I don't think there's a way around that because humans are just too diverse,
but is it possible that one day we'll move past this?
I mean,
is there any plans at all to try to facilitate some sort of a peaceful world
civilization where,
you know,
all nations kind of get along and some sort of a mutually agreeable way?
I mean,
does anybody have some sort of hundred year plan?
Isn't that hilarious?
That,
that's a funny thing to say.
I mean,
they didn't brief me on it if it exists.
Isn't that fucked though?
I mean,
human beings are always going to shoot and kill each other.
We're always going to have war.
Isn't that fucked?
Since the inception of human beings,
it seems like,
at least at some level,
and it thankfully it's microscopic in comparison to the overall total,
but it's happening.
I think it's happened since man has been walking on earth and the only way that
we feel today that we can protect ourselves is to have the more dominant,
more powerful military and to make sure that we're the ones who get to dictate
whether or not evil flourishes.
Yeah,
I mean that's,
I would want a,
maybe a,
I want the,
the dominant ability of our military to continue to grow,
but I'd like to see,
and I think it's already moving this direction,
smaller,
more surgical uses of it.
I just,
the military in my opinion,
is not good at building infrastructure and holding terrain for a long period of
time.
It's just not what we're designed to do.
Right.
It's not the design of the military for that matter.
What,
what is the overall view about getting out of Syria?
It probably depends on the people that you ask.
What about people that you talk to?
Okay.
Both sides of the coin.
I will get answers from.
I think we're making a difference too.
We're wasting our time
and I got that on the initial invasion of Iraq,
the initial invasion of Afghanistan.
There is one of the things that I enjoyed about the community I came from is
that critical thinking was it's rewarded.
It's not,
there's no attempt and people think about this,
you know,
you watched full metal jacket,
choke yourself with my hand and you get told what to do and how to do it,
how much time you have to do it.
People think that critical thinking has no place in the military.
But where I came from that's we're looking for is people who are able to
critically think.
So they would be,
we would have political arguments,
religious arguments,
philosophical arguments in the team room and then come together and go do
exactly what it is that our nation expected us to do.
So you're going to get both.
You get I,
there are people who are conservative and Liberal,
Republican and Democrat and everything in between.
So I wish I could give you a,
like a very precise answer,
but I have heard every spectrum of answer from this is awesome to,
this is stupid.
I've,
you know what confuses me?
I've heard different opinions on the sod,
whether Assad is evil,
whether he's gassed his,
his citizens or whether or not he's a victim of propaganda,
some mass smear campaign like,
Whoa,
this is way past my pay grade.
I've heard the same thing and it's beyond mine as well too.
It's frustrating because you know when you don't know whether or not this is
some propaganda or this is a real threat or whether you know he or whether it's
something like the Saddam Hussein situation where yes,
he was an evil dictator but also removing him.
Mike create a power vacuum like Libya had a power vacuum.
Yup.
Kadafi with Libya.
I mean Libya is a horrific example of that,
right?
Yeah.
And I don't,
I don't know the longterm solution to those problems.
It's like I said,
I,
I spend enough of my waking hours truly questioning whether or not anything that
I was involved in made my family or your family or Jamie's family safer did.
I did,
I did my actions.
You road what the rest of the world thinks about the United States of America.
And I mean I,
I flew back and forth.
I think it had an impact in the moment.
I think it had an impact stopping the water coming out of the dam.
I think it was essential that it needed to be done.
But I don't know if any of that has an impact beyond that,
that time period that it occurred.
How much does it help you in uh,
talking about this stuff to give you a perspective,
like a no cleared hot your podcasts yet you're very active with that.
How much does,
does that help you flesh these ideas out and have conversations about them?
One of the most Cathartic things that I do is talk on the podcast about these
topics.
So,
and I'll do mix between guests and Q and a.
And guess what people ask me about.
They want to know about war and they want to know about that stuff.
And it forces me to sit there and truly
gauge the depth of my beliefs and then answer the questions for myself as to why
do I believe this?
It is by far one of the most Cathartic things that I have done is the ability to
sit down and reflect.
And I mean,
I'm pretty honest about,
I mean,
if people ask me about killing,
I'll talk about killing people,
ask me about mistakes.
I'll tell you the worst mistakes that I ever made.
Parenting a relationship with my wife,
military fill in the blank.
Um,
so it's been huge and be honest.
I mean,
you know,
this,
I owe,
I owe the suggestion from you to start in that podcast.
I owe you a huge thank you for giving me that nudge.
Well,
you're so good.
You're,
you're,
you were great on my podcast.
You know,
I just knew you would do great at it.
Yeah.
Um,
uh,
I dunno,
I probably have said to too many people,
you should start a podcast,
but it's worked with so many with Jocko phenomenal.
And I bet it's Cathartic for him as well too.
I haven't,
I haven't asked him about it,
but I would suspect that it's the same thing.
Yeah,
he's a,
he's a unique human.
He's an American treasure.
He should go into the time capsule at next to Jerry.
Number one.
You really should,
man.
He's something special,
but it's also like in terms of motivation,
he's a mindset alterer like you,
you hear the way he discusses things and thinks about things and if you can
adopt those ideas and put them into your own head,
you really can shift who you are and,
and how you move through this world.
If you can adopt a fraction of his ideas or it'll change your philosophy.
There are some people that I see go very,
like they have seemed to be searching and they,
they just want to dive in.
It's like,
you know,
maintain some of yourself and adopt as much as that as you possibly can because
you can go too far in anything.
But yeah,
the stuff that he's doing at the number of people,
that number of times,
his name comes up and it in a positive manner.
It's unbelievable.
And I mean,
I listened to the chair you where you're like,
you know what,
Jocko,
I'm going to tell you something that I think I've said too much.
You should start a puck.
Well,
you know,
Goggins is another one.
You know Goggins just being a guest on this podcast.
I know he hasn't started his own podcast,
but one thing he did do is if you listen to Goggins a audio book in his audio
book,
He has the book itself,
which is read by a another guy.
And then him and that guy discuss various chapters in the book and discuss the
real events that led to this,
these different things and how he felt about them.
So it's a podcast wrapped up in a book and it's excellent.
So much better than just reading a chapter and verse,
all that additional information and,
and all the,
the breadth and depth that you can gather from that.
It's an incredible medium.
I didn't,
I don't,
I think I told you this,
I had never listened to a podcast before I came on years.
So I tend,
well,
we went a little crazy on that one.
And I've maybe,
you know,
I talked to a touch about Guantanamo Bay and,
but I still say the same thing.
I just maybe would have been more educated about the breadth and depth of your
podcast.
It's,
I didn't realize at the fee,
and again I'm a fraction in comparison to other podcasts out there,
but even the volume of response that I get to mind,
it's unbelievable.
The number of people who are consuming this type of medium is mindblowing.
Well,
it's free,
which is great.
And it's also,
it's easy.
You get it on your phone instantly.
So you could be in your car,
your phone is Bluetooth up to your car and that you say,
oh,
there's a nuclear hot Bam,
you press play.
It starts playing.
Yeah.
And because,
you know,
essentially it's a audio is not that,
it's not that big a file.
It can stream really easily over four g like instantaneously.
It's uh,
it's amazing.
It's just to end it to have everything free and instantly accessible like that.
So if you're a truck driver of you're driving long distances for work or if
you're traveling on a plane and you can scroll,
pick a topic.
Yeah,
I mean,
what do you want to learn about that podcast out there for it?
Whatever it is for anything.
There's crime,
podcasts and there's comedy podcasts and politics and technology.
It's like it's never ending and there's hundreds and hundreds of thousands of
them and they're all free.
Yeah.
So it's an,
it's an amazing medium and it's also a medium with a very low gate of entry.
Like it's not difficult to jump over that gate or to get through all you.
Really all you need is an account somewhere.
Yep.
And then you can do,
I've done a bunch of them just with my iPhone,
just using the voice recorder application from voice notes from a podcast,
from a iPhone,
record it,
and then I'll send it to Jamie and Jamie will upload them.
Like we've done a bunch of them on planes or just me and Tony Hinchcliffe was
sat on a plane and we have a couple of cocktails start talking shit into the,
into the I end of the phone.
Yeah.
It's crazy.
And then you know,
that reaches a million people.
Yeah.
I mean,
you know,
100 bucks,
it's,
you could start a podcast for 400 bucks.
You get a recording device and some way to gather the sound and you're off and
running.
Yeah.
And there's so many people out there with unique perspectives.
Like you lucked Jocko luck.
There's a,
there's hundreds of them.
You know,
it's just to,
it's a exciting time,
you know,
started to get to the medium.
Well listen,
we did said fucking three hours.
How crazy is that?
It's almost four o'clock.
It always feels like,
like 90 minutes.
I know.
Most of the time warp in this room,
man,
there's something weird.
I think it's this table.
So I'm going on.
It seems to be it.
Andy,
I love you buddy.
Thanks for having me.
Appreciate your man Andy stuff.
Ladies and gentlemen,
cleared hot podcast available everywhere I go.
Get it by.
Hmm.
Yeah.